[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
time
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
food
[Music]
do
[Music]
hey
[Music]
uh
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
know
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
hey what's up everyone and welcome to
the dragon ball fighterz world
championship tenkaichi online master
challenge we are running through europe
to today that is united kingdom ireland
and netherlands a top eight to run
through 200 points on the line and of
course i'm joined by another man like c4
what's up c4
what's going on damascus thank you for
letting me come back two days on the
truck loving it though
man i miss dragon ball man i miss high
level dragon for sure but uh yeah uh
after yesterday proper hyped and
obviously we're in the bits this is the
uk side absolutely first so i'll curve
my bias and be as professional as
possible i promise uh but yeah like
let's just have a look at it right let's
check out the players let's check out of
course we're gonna run through the top
eight of this tournament this is the
bracket for today we got plug the winner
stays on champion from two weeks ago
napa player excellent player uh against
face al dante then we got siridan versus
taser after that's gonna be jugs and
nuestra familia from the netherlands and
then wolfshadow against fullmetal fury
from
the uk a pretty
interesting topic couple of missing
names i would say before we even talk
about any other medicine games ob
assassin did not enter could not enter
neither did ramsey
both of them busy live events
so
the question is answered already right
irl reflected and uh stopped them from
coming in but we do have a good
representation i think for the uk
especially like you said with plug yeah
having a big offline win last week and
an event that rmz and ob were both at
yeah so
he's definitely proved himself faisal
kind of coming back out i know he took a
break for a little bit uh realized i
think as well um very
uh
he's been studying he's definitely been
studying his opponents if anyone's been
watching his on his stream uh and then
yeah sheridan
one of the uh the og gods he got world
tour points and he was number one on a
leaderboard for pc yeah
i could never take that away from him
this is the man who grinds a hell of a
lot in uh this taser of course is a
samia i mean i'm not a newcomer but a
fairly like if you consider the full
life lifetime of the game a fairly
recent addition you know to the uk
roster and he's been really grinding
doing well consistent top eight winners
position for him uh it's gonna be
interesting and danny losers got jugs uh
one of the best from netherlands against
the only player i'm not familiar with in
this top 8 c4 familia
yes same here uh i don't even think i've
seen them on either of our streams yeah
i've only heard rumors of them from
people like nick fisher out to them
who's like a very prominent figure in
the uh
the netherlands scene
so yeah i'm i saw them use base for geo
and that's all i know so hopefully we
get uh pleasantly surprised yeah i will
uh i would be interested in this and
then last but not least this warp shadow
well known from the netherlands and uh
last not least against full metal fury
you know what that means as well c4
two nappas interfered
two h's let's go we're getting we're
getting mixturization today that's going
to be a very very entertaining topic to
watch i know a lot of you guys who are
joining might not be familiar with these
players because you guys
don't watch enough dragon ball you
should join every turn on both stuff
around because we have a lot of fun with
this and speaking of it guys plenty of
dragon ball content this is the dragon
fighters world championship what is the
drama fighters world championship let's
quickly run through that guys of course
world championship is going to be a
format that will run from now on until
early 2022 you have a ton of dragon ball
fighters to look forward to here is the
format we start with the tenkaichi
online challenges from september to
november uh these are online events uh
to qualify to then the regional finals
in december that are uh in uh that's
gonna be offline in december and then
the people who qualify through each of
the regional finals will qualify
straight to the world championship final
early 2022 offline as well a lot of
offline dragon ball fighters to look
forward to as for the online sides we
got two types of events on one side
we've got the community tournaments all
of the tournament organizers for dragon
ball fighters are
free to join the world championship to
run tournaments that will grant points
to their players community events will
encourage the community to be part of it
there are already plenty of tio shout
out to them who are part of this and the
master challenges uh like this one today
like the one you might have seen
yesterday for europe for last week was
the west coast as well all of these
grant a ton of points c4 this master
challenge that's the one everyone should
attend right
yeah the point differential that we're
going to see on the screen now is
mahusiv look at that first place gives
200 points and then from the 10 catches
if you get 74 members uh or more you get
100 to win so even if you come second in
this point uh in this tournament that's
a bag of points that
once you get that it's going to be very
hard for people to catch up to you as
possible yeah but it's going to be very
hard so yeah a lot of uh
a big opportunity comes your way if you
get even like top three in this
tournament so it's very important for
the players yeah this is massive like i
think right now and i feel like
especially in the regions where uh
because tournaments in the uk are around
30ish players uh so you know like the
the the community online tournaments
will grant 25 45 today is massively
important uh for this the online
challenges are both on pc and ps4 the
master events are on pc but the
community events are free to run either
on pc or ps4 for everyone who wants to
join and these are the arena zones we've
got japan we've got europe one which is
france uh belgium luxembourg and
switzerland we go to europe too which is
the current region aka uk ireland and
netherlands europe 3 which is spain
portugal and italy and europe 4 that
you've seen yesterday which is germany
denmark norway and sweden then north
america west north america east and
former regions name of brazil mexico
australia and middle east
all of these struggling fighting to get
to these regional finals what are the
regional finals c4 first off they're
offline and look at this
this december this month of december the
first three weekend of december each
weekend will be a regional final offline
so you guys know i mean i already know
what i'm doing in december i hope i hope
you guys know as well
i'm logging off christmas mate we've got
no time for christmas dragon ball full
month let's go christmas coming uh early
you know for us and how do this regional
final work so 12 players
on each regional final eight invited
players and four qualifiers that qualify
through these online events if you have
a quote the b esports announcement on
the twitter the
the guests for the european regions have
already been announced it's wawa kaiden
yasha
wade shanks gropis and mr popo are the
eight invited players that you will see
in regional finals yesterday we've seen
panda winning europe four he which puts
him maybe one foot already in this
original finals as long as he keeps
going on the online events we've seen
zayn in the us as well doing really well
in winning the uh the west coast event
so all of these players are already
getting closer and closer to this
regional finals regional finals will
play in round robin formats
and at the end of it four players from
each regional final will qualify to the
big 1c for the world championship final
what dreams are made of man this is what
everyone's been playing for man for a
long time as well just
grinding online knowing not really
seeing the like the end of the tunnel
but you tyron and everyone else in the
works have brought this opportunity here
it's going to be a hard struggle but
there you go world championship finals
watch championship fight guys early 2022
offline we finally get the entire world
of dragon ball uh together i can't wait
for this and of course regional finals
which means you're gonna have the
european finals first then the us uh
then the japan the guests for us and
japan have not been announced yet they
will be announced soon of course make
sure you follow b and e esports for this
so quick summary of this in europe there
are four regions first place of each
region guess the original finals in usa
two regions top two of each region guest
regional finals in japan
it's an entire top four online that will
join the original finals and then top
four of each regional finals will get
straight to the final and then for the
former regions uh getting an lcq format
especially the first place of each of
these regions mexico australia brazil
and middle east will go straight to the
world championship final that's a ton of
a dragon ball to look forward to and of
course if you guys want to enter if you
want to enter you you have to join the
dbfz esports portal i believe the
comment is exclamation dbfdwc on the
chat to get that link make sure you sign
up you have all of the schedule for
every single event in your area so make
sure you go make sure you join the
master events and any event that you
could do i believe it's wc i'm not sure
if the mods can correct me on this that
would be really a really cool app
for this and of course theos same guys
you can join the dragon ball fighters
esports portal to
apply to put your events in and just to
enjoy i've seen plenty of tios around
the world going absolutely harm i've
seen in the east coast tournaments with
more than 100 entrants uh it's it's it's
kind of it's exclamation wc thank you
there we go
slick
utilizing the power of the swords shout
out to the mods yeah that's uh
that's that's we want so the original
the original finals you will you will
know the guests for america and japan
very soon stay tuned on twitter there
will be announce uh but today of course
it's all about
the uk
ireland and netherlands the bracket is
about to start and our first players for
today are plug
and face al dante
these two players about to face each
other and you know i mean i mean we were
chatting before this if one and i was
saying that
i do think
that looking at the status of this event
i think plug might be the favorite man i
mean i'm not quite sure like i haven't
seen face all dante competing in a while
so i'm not sure how high of a level he
is
but
like it's it's looking it's ridiculous
like i really want to see what is facial
dentist level
yeah no i agree i i think this could be
in any other timeline this could be the
grand finals and it's kind of like uh
two different
not just different players but two
different like uh
characters because plugs fairly new he's
played other games before he's gone into
the hot body time chamber training with
people like raw kid jake people from the
uk uh comes out
uh at wednesdays on
cleaned everyone up yeah all the way
through winners yeah no stood the chance
yeah and like i said people at ob and
rmz were there father on the other hand
even though he's young he's kind of an
og right he was very strongly marvel
insane execution the the consistency
this guy has online
is actually amazing like he doesn't play
like abc characters he plays really high
execution characters deals with it being
an online and adapts to it so we're
going to see a lot of madness we're
going to see stylish combos from zamasu
we're going to get dirty mixes from napa
that's what's looking good man and i
remember like the the start of that top
eight is in first to two
and then we move to four to top four we
do all of this in first two uh three so
right now it's gonna be for us to two
between plug and facil dante the two
players about to face each other and i
think yeah this is the question right
because i've said i'm not entirely sure
where faisal stands like is he peak face
all is he i'm getting back to it faisal
like that's that's the question that i'm
asking today uh because plug is
definitely playing the best i've ever
seen him lately
yeah so
the only information i could get because
i i don't know i'm not like you know
he's liaison i'm not like part of the
fiasco entourage i don't know what he's
been doing but in this tournament he had
to be raw kid to get here yeah in
winterside so he's not had like an easy
path so he's still got it that might be
just enough to get the top eight like
we're gonna see if plug is gonna you
know show him the levels uh but yeah if
we've seen files before he picks up
games really quickly
from when he was streaming today the
execution's still there it never left
the muscle memory is still on point
the only thing that could be his flaw is
not being playing much of the new patch
and not ready for what the opponent is
going to throw at him that could be his
other problem because he's got the
blocks yeah he's definitely got the
blocks but if he doesn't know what to
block
that's not going to help him right does
he does he know about st sardone that's
what the s and the t stands for cyberman
let's see if he knows listen the
cyberman i know like a lot of uh a lot
of uh complains about napa where that
napa has no neutral napa is a smart
businessman he outsources neutral he has
contracted
yeah he's sub contracting the neutral
cyberman tiber man do the job for him
100 percent
however when you said that i was like
that's actually what he's doing actual
entrepreneur
the businessman he's here
literally in a second but
dante with the yamcha so i know
faisal was learning other characters
because you know
he pretty much got clowned on and
grilled for playing yamcha uh but he
makes the character the teamwork sorry
maybe not the character the teamwork the
synergy is there people are saying i'll
just pick like basically or something
else to replace yamcha and he was saying
that he's going into this with the
familiarity of yamcha yeah he
understands that there might be better
characters and he can learn new routes
but familiarity is what is important
when you get to somewhere like this a
top eight winner side you can't just go
oh basically is better let me just win
with him it doesn't work like that
it's not easy right like when you have
the muscle memory with the character
when you you know go through this when
you're able to like confirm every single
little moment of the character it's hard
to just like go immediately from another
one so that is going to be facial
dante's project a very uh you know
season two-ish looking team with the
bordeaux yamcha that used to be a
the prime shell back in the days
that was premiere mate we saw that all
the time at top eight and now this is a
luxury right seeing this character these
two characters on top eight and faisal
keeping it old school
nice mix and here we go god punch damn
before i miss seeing that i i definitely
didn't i definitely the classic you know
keeping the plus frames all right floyd
we're gonna wait looking for that 2m not
gonna happen just yet and the base goku
assist is gonna open man up plug just
gonna put him down and now gets a
potential
trying to open him up there is one
assistant makes remaining oh no the
reflect what's the face out
yeah and that's reflected super smart
because he didn't commit to larry
straight away right he waited to see
what was gonna happen then went for it
and now getting
paid off in dividends here we go
come win plug in the corner that spark
is going to expire
damascus the power
of the autocombo
absolutely working on this gets the
dragon rush and he's going to go to for
zamasu's level three probably gonna go
found our mixer behind this
[Music]
they need to high low get opened up that
should be a dead knapper and that's a
huge threat eliminating from clogged
steam
and we were talking about maybe farsi
not knowing i don't i don't know if plug
knows about the new zamasu stuff mate
you might see growth has played but i
don't know if he's experienced it so
this could be a shock to the system for
both players
wait that traded with something
yeah that was full in h i i didn't know
that trading
i definitely clashed with zamasu's jh oh
my gosh and his fist clashed with his
dome head i think plug he's got no
assist but he might not need it to get
the kill here and zamasu
can you get
oh no plug
no i think he could have just level five
maybe i wonder because he can't get uh
genkidama with the blue goku to place
two right
i
don't think so wow that was amazing talk
to my hand and that should be more than
enough for face adapted to get the kill
build a ton of meter and not even use
one the bank is full of seven bars for
face al dante the spark is about to get
away but a super good first match for
him
yeah oh jumps away no super straight
away but
clips plug when his last character zero
mall plan is trying to be established
here he's got one more character on the
worst tonight 360 no let's go we got him
get out get out the pressure is there
got to watch out right now oh the guard
console to just get away good one from
plug no conversion from face all dante
starting to look very very long for plug
right now
yeah this is rough right no spark
let's go i forgot that distracts full
screen c4 that was such a smart option
from plug
[Music]
i mean oh no plug again doesn't get the
vanish confirmed but apparently he
doesn't need it the nice air to air but
yes plug
utilizing all the tools that brought to
the table with his team sniping
man like zamasu as yeah what a good
option to have
absolutely let's see trying to keep some
more pressure right now but plug waiting
oh the opening goes to dante he's got a
good amount of bars he can do level two
into level one that should be more than
enough for level three only that should
kill anyway face al dante
taking a convincing first game we were
asking
what is facial dentist level right now
and god damn pretty good man
is this up there man it feels like
people think like he might have fell
behind but he was at such a high level
to start with people been catching up to
him if you think about it right he's
very consistent with his team like we
said
and yeah his team might not be like the
best characters but when it when they
hit you you know why they're strong but
he's one of the few a few players that
kind of puts the synergy to the
forefront not that oh i've got this
character that can do this it's the
whole squad right and we saw like that
pre-smart combo he did he did like 70
and he was halfway through it without
supers yeah like his damage his damage
in on his team is actually insane he was
laughing like oh yeah if i've got like
four or five bars and i hate with two he
died yeah but i don't need spark at that
point yeah anywhere on screen it's it's
crazy so plug needs to look out and we
saw the reactions right damascus with
that 2h on the dive kick that guy kicks
pretty quick like
and he just got the character today
sorry to expose you he didn't have blue
until today to level this stuff so
i i'm i would be scared going up against
someone who could adapt that quick
absolutely face atlanta left the lobby
i'm not sure why just waiting for him to
rejoin so one nil on his side i must say
we have not seen plug in a threatening
situation just yet faisal has really
managed this absolutely perfectly that
first game completely went on his side
but remember that plug is a momentum
beast one opening one mix situation and
it's a good luck
yeah i think
i don't think it's a flaw but it's just
his game strategy right we've seen it
and if anyone saw uh the tournament
where it was plug versus yasha he beat
yasha and like you said he is momentum
when anyone's like standing in front of
the avalanche that is plug pressure
most people crumble and i don't think he
got it started i think he was kind of
bamboozled a little bit by the zamasu
again a character that benefit i feel a
lot from the last patch and plays very
different
so
you either go okay i need to understand
what he's doing or i need to do what i
need to do oh sorry i need to do what my
plan is stronger and just throw out rock
rock rock and a rock paper this is a
game and eventually you win right that's
kind of what napa does right it's five h
can i get a plant out okay can i get a
planet now five eight can i get a plan
out when you get that plant out
everyone's a victim yeah it's definitely
uh what i want to see so far extremely
good first game for face al dante one
nil for him one game away from a
winner's final face album
looking to get his win can't plug bring
it back
tried to go for the air to air there
zamasu a very good at clearing the
screen the overcomer commitment
oh the pokemon dashboard this is the
pogo
he tried he tried to dashboard there but
not working and right now plug
putting man down he's got an assist to
try and mix him with that blue crew face
all dante forced to block we've seen a
lot of reflect earlier by face i'll
don't they could be flanked but no the 5
ll
oh no
zamasu spoiler
and blue still gets to confirm nice go
for the side swap
oh gets the hit but no conversion will
be too far to get anything greater my
plug plug trying to go for the elbow but
dante gets out from that challenge not
trying to jail and straight to the spark
yeah it doesn't want to have to block
any of the overhead nonsense and a spot
back by plug and again you've said this
before we've always been talking about
plug-in
but let's talk about plugs jaw right now
because that thing got spun by bardock
and income zamasu
yeah we're gonna get judged
judge this character
i tried to get away good one and he's
getting his own opening right now and
you know what napa comes up
gonna go for this gets to assist behind
no decides to plan the cyberman on the
right this time right now you got like
17 mixes
right now and there we go the opening
goes to plug that was the light opener
so i don't think he can kill he's gonna
need a re-stand again with base goku
gets the dragon rush what's it gonna be
no doesn't go for the v stand just for
the cyberman but gets him
okay here we go still in the same
apartment
street corner
can he get out
protect this time
for him
no one heard the call
oh no that's gonna hurt oh that that
should be a dead zamasu
and i like that plug goes for the easy
combo does not go for the regen does not
go for something he could
drop just make sure he finishes his play
that's a dead zamasu
tournament optimal combos that's what we
like to see vanessa you know about those
ones so the most optimal combo is the
one that kills
and pluggers had a notorious like
represent uh
rep for doing combos that aren't
necessary in dropping them and joking
exactly being necessary is
this and if you ever think
that you should do the optimal combos to
win remember that kazunoko won an entire
world tour without doing a single
optimal combo or the whole year
i don't go like he played adol gohan for
a year and never did a leg loop and he
won the world tour
and with the character never seen right
now that fell out of favor yamcha
decides
what no way
no
wait don't tell me that was on purpose
because if that was on purpose that was
the sickest defensive option i've seen
all day mix get to the reflect but no we
still got mixes behind and that's gonna
be another opening for plug plug should
get more than enough to get the kill
right now one assist into a second
assist there dragon rush i think it's
one and three is enough
yeah he's dead with
dips and the extra side of fries i
i don't want to call blogger master all
right so i'm gonna go i'm gonna air this
out of course and go with you i think he
knew he's allowed that but that looked
crazy right
that clash was mental that honestly like
i'm gonna ask plug after this well was
that on purpose or did you just try to
escape and and it happened to clash
because we needed
[Laughter]
not trying to use the the
male addiction
not today
there we go there we go
this is the combo
momentum right
three characters remaining
kind of to a degree steamrolled i think
it was hard at points with the neutral
getting faster to block but once fazer
did block
he could do it until
until the manure was put on the ground
the seeds were planted and then it gets
a little bit too much right yeah
this is when uh when plug becomes very
very scary excellent play my plug is one
one one game to decide who moves to
winners final and who moves to first to
three territory as well you know like
that's that's a
place you want to be in to just have
some more time to play your sets to
adapt to the opponents and you know
that's that's the luxury both players
wants
for sure for sure and like i said faisal
has been practicing uh between his
tournament played to now uh one of the
things
i was in the stream chat just seeing
like how he was doing because obviously
we haven't seen him for a while and i
was saying oh you ready for like the new
mechanics like the guard cats will
vanish and everyone was sending little
propaganda everyone was telling him i'll
just block it i was like no no no it
doesn't work like that you can't just
block it and plug was showing
that you can't just you can't just react
to him yeah it's two bars it's a very
strong attack right it's a vanish it
freezes the screen and then your plus
yeah absolutely
let's see for now the first opening oh
no he went for a tap dear he's not
believed in his button face are looking
for an opening good blocks by plugs
gonna be the corner but the trim opening
oh
that feels so bad the mattress you know
you flinch because he saw the first two
a whiff and then the two m comes out of
nowhere big boy damage here bar duke
that is the first time i see a button
between yeah
i can't climb but you know you know what
time is it
you know what time is it c4 um
oh what time is it
oh he dropped it's okay i still got me
it's okay
even if i dropped my business partner
here the blue cyberman
does it for me
the full truth insurance policy plan
come in effect napa
into blue goku into the base form and
that is going to be zamasu
possibly fossils flagship character are
going out in the last
game this set
this is uh starting to uh look good for
plug but remember it's still two
characters still a shell that face up
then they have played four years
oh my god that was a street fighter
jumping get out
yeah and he ducked after the 5x as well
he looked like he was probably thinking
about trying to to hate it but just
didn't get on time but it's under
pressure
vermin
face are trying to press the button but
plug not letting him get any of that
plug looking super good in the set to
move towards that windows final
and
this is looking nothing like the first
round right like
we've been saying this the momentum is
so important to both of these players
uh you look at a loss and go oh they got
watched it's not like that it's just the
momentum is so strong it's very hard to
come back from yamcha let's see if five
was going in because this would be
monumental if you can make this happen
but plug is trying to deny good 2h scene
in flinch the massacres i think it might
be a guess for the game here
oh no he did the wrong beam
yeah straight to the spot you've got
you've got to do that part you've got to
try and get some mileage of this one
plug now just waiting for us to block
and that's good ooh steals the corner of
course the first opening goes to face al
dante side switch back to the corner we
go
saves the bar i respect that spark
because you use that spark just to beat
some of this parking timer
yes
100 100 percent oh but
oh this is this is how it goes downhill
right yeah you just spark so you're not
going to be able to
use any resources to get out of pressure
right
or knock down situations and
yamcha's still got the whole left right
with the corner level 3 that's still
something alright so here's the question
right exactly like i was about to say
call the blue assist into cyberman good
the simon got punched up good blocks by
plug he's waiting for the assist i think
block strategy will be this assists into
cyberman but good one to just get away
from the assist that actually beats the
guard council the vessel dante might be
on his way to a massive comeback
he's ruining the cannon this is not how
this fight went there's nothing on the
right stage that is that that is the
yamcha you know like i don't know if
you've read the
the yamcha one
yeah they have to dream oh
dates as well no freaking way face al
dante pulls it down to blue goku and
it's a 1v1
2021 are we gonna see a yamcha comeback
is that potentially on the table right
here damascus
oh
oh my oh my god you actually got five
bars
that was voodoo i don't think you oh no
this is limit break limit level five i
don't think he's dead i don't think he's
dead
chad do the maths i believe
i don't know actually i might have
lights
he's alive right no what touchy for him
for real the reflect who's gonna open
the open on top first got to watch out
i'm doing no face i'll dante had the
opening he's gonna try to move it more
got to watch out he knows he's not gonna
go for that because plug was pressing
them buttons jading and i'm not sure
what face al dante did
but
the dreams of comeback
first game by the way
first game with this top eight i'm
astonished at the levels like
i was kind of memean about the younger
comeback it was definitely on the table
and yeah he didn't hit confirm the first
sd the super dash she got right he went
straight into dark that that would have
been
he could just have hit vanish after that
superdome actually he could just have
done vanish into a simple combo that is
extremely unfortunate but plug
take a breather mate you made it but at
what cost
oh
vanish on the close-up and
the voodoo curse stuff happened but just
to plug apparently he's always ready for
all those interactions that we think are
random he's ready for it that's that's
why he's good right it looks crazy to us
but he's like yeah it's cool if you see
him in person he's actually like that
it's really crazy so uh
plug in winner's finals taking it 2-1
over faisal that last match was that
whole set was sick back forth and such a
nail bar at the end
but we're gonna go into the next
winner's side match
shuri you dan versus taser one three
that's absolutely
an interesting one of course uh two
players who grind the game uh like crazy
to read and of course one of the biggest
like online grind kind of player uh that
we got you know the scene uh you know
he's there as you said right he's top of
the leaderboards on pc uh he's always
always always grinding the game playing
a deadly
super saiyan 4 gogeta based team he's
gonna face tyser and i'm trying to think
because i think these two faced
at wino stazon
did they think it was off stream i think
it was upstream and i think sheridan won
i think i think you're right
i think you're right like they faced of
stream because i remember i was running
the brackets for this and i remember
calling them and be like you have to
play each other so
i i mean you know that is like the one
that's uh that's a run back to get of
course but taser has definitely been
grinding that game like crazy getting
better and better and he plays a team
with hits now
yeah i i saw the hit and i was
i've seen taser plays a lot of teams for
people that don't know he used to just
pick oh tell me the best three
characters and not play that he used to
play gt i guess he's still playing ui i
know he tried gogeta for a minute uh
shuri down on the other hand picked
godzilla at the beginning
uh when he dropped was like he's okay
and then before the 5v5 was going his
character's broken everyone like you
actually don't understand how dumb this
character is
so
don't don't look at shuridan's team and
think he's just picking koji because
he's the flavor of the market he picked
that literally they won but yeah like he
said taser plays a lot of teams go into
the hit uh something you
kind of got to be brave to do in the uk
right because of ob and rmz yeah it's
kind of like everyone knows what this
character is capable of on offense but
taser in wso i think he got fourth so he
did really well it was full for fifth
one of those two
he definitely did really well uh at our
first offline in london but let's see
right now siridan immediately getting
the first opening i'm gonna go for the
first level up with great tech by taser
[Music]
wow
no
man said no
oh no the drop that is so crucial that's
the worst bit right it's right at the
end all you needed to dr he potentially
could have maybe even killed knowing
that he's got tien on his side right
oh neutral
yeah this is this is called footsies
if you if you wanted to ask it's the
neutral it goes to level three
with that person for gojita and puts
your goku down
straight to the spot oh
yeah it sparks after that not concerned
maybe want some momentum dp
2-2 s and you take your turn back
blocks of super dash but not the 6n
damascus oh he's going to build a lot of
bar here
all right gets hit in
and that's going to be important to kill
that super saiyan 4 gojita
get away you invested in levels the
investment does not pay out
the market has crashed market has
crashed
go play discreet game if you want money
but you don't get this today
ready oh no the legs got blessed stepped
on the crepes now he's gonna get
good 2m starter reflect and taser just
backs away sees that he's got a life
lead and knows he doesn't have to engage
but sure then doesn't care he will make
you engage oh
all right let's see for the full screen
straight to reflect watch out for the
reflecting on hit you can see that's red
and immediately stop reflecting knowing
you can't just reflect that character
sorry then gets his opening
yep gets the knees
gets a level three and takes the sparks
off the table so what's he gonna do here
get hit apparently
all right
good mix good mix
we take those
we take those sometimes you get mixed
all right 2v1 so we're done
oh my god i was like what's that vanish
but no oh you're dead
i want handshakes spark have that hands
are definitely been shaking
he could have sparked when he saw that
that vanished before the super but but
you've got to be next level work to know
about this oh great conversion sure
yeah that that wasn't pretty well
conversion oh then going for the
slapping here because it's got some
armor but i don't know how well it works
against gogeta and his limbs and the
mole hit him oh nice one that's good now
go for a long combo you don't care it's
blue life i know but you're wasting
sparking time and that's exactly what
you need right now trying to go for the
mix punish one vanish to get some more
pressure and that's really good that's
that spark is really really getting away
from surrey then
it is slowly but surely and all that far
as well i think he went into it with six
and now he's only got one he's building
it back and this is tn if he gets hit
you're going to know about it
but taser that's a solid defense for a
wife
you know what
you want a
defense i like your cut g
dead
man got bonked
horny on main not today
i would have been sick
watch out here there is no battle so
he's not gonna get much probably putting
him in a one-touch situation
it's a full screen battle great reflect
by a taser i can't not believe he
reflected this
yeah he's brave
he's brave
oh windy punch you've got three bars
go to the mix same side
i'm sorry could have killed all this
that's okay no
okay
okay
all right we like i was about to
feel very sad
for apologizer
because that could have killed twice in
a row he decided to wait for the third
one
yo that was
that yeah that was just squeaky that was
just all squeaks because
clearly sheridan tried to reflect the
second year of the all combo and pretend
you go for punish but it whipped so he
was just there
clapping his hands together like tien
does on his reflect and yeah taser
bringing it back because at the start
from that 2h sure then looked like he
was taking no prisoners in this set
absolutely he really started strong but
respect to taser he brought it back
really really quickly and right now he
is the one on the lead one game away
from joining his boy plug in winners
finals
yeah first or two sure dan can not
afford to lose any more gains if you
want to avoid that loser's side strong
round star
hit a
i feel like i haven't seen it for a
while
i'm just like
that's why
it's been
[Music]
how do you do commerce from the third
hit of war combo is it even over him i
don't know yeah i think he was
more baffled that he actually got the
hit
all right trying to get in and the
dragon rush is going to open to read and
up the defense on siridan has not been
clean taser is finding a lot of openings
here we go knock down ui
gets pressured
oh no and the mind games yeah the plus
frames right it's just a mind game if
you go from dr strike and
julian guess where i'm going from the
reflect it's gonna have to put his hands
up as hit hit some of the level three
one touchy
can you get him down or try to
ronaldinho again but this time sweden
was ready guess the opening but no
conversion and tiene wins the battle of
a sister
oh that's really cool
expensive confirmed but
can't put price on advantage here we go
and get that that blue life back as well
very important oh he's getting happier
they know he didn't see
he did not realize that happy birthday
was on could have potentially sparked
and killed that gojita but guess the
dragon rush regardless that's a dead hit
yeah you're right i think
just going straight into spark would
have been good there but yeah maybe he
didn't see the character behind in the
background uh
not too bad though he still got the the
advantage driver the health still got
his spark intact which isn't too bad
that was a sick confirm stop
it all right down into level three
time for the mix is he gonna go for the
fuzzy behind
straight to spark i was trying to bait
something anyway oh no two h on this
things are not ready and i like street
then trying to answer this stay there
blocking good blocks
yeah very strong blocks there oh the m
did not reach
this is going to be big damage i don't
think he's going to lose the gogeta but
going to be in a very peculiar situation
does he spark here oh no maybe he loses
his character
yeah
level two level three that's done
that is done
or is it am i lying
i think he is the best
yeah okay good we don't lie we don't lie
here let's get this 2v2 spark still
there on cerritos
good big buttons from
uh
good
build some of that meter back oops get
all of that meter is he gonna get that
third bar no he won't great take once
again by
payza then he's gonna get his own
conversion and that is going to be a
solid amount of damage there i don't
think he can kill
i don't know i'm gonna say no
i'm gonna go yes just for the contrabass
chats tell us quick
highlights
yes i
self-censoring self-firing that's it
done let's go watch out 10 weeks part 10
look at that
for your main again
don't do it again
yeah okay reflect rings and go gr blue
hair variety
prolonging this combo like you mentioned
earlier all right just kill that smart
type and on tn that's the most important
thing you can do right now yeah and i
think you know grenita is good because
his combos are long
and he's just waiting right now baiting
something the opening but no conversion
oh we need to go to confirm there i
think sheridan's looking to uh slap him
out of the air if he tries to sweep that
one more time oh
oh no
oh this is safe
yeah
yeah it's also a mix-up you can get
crossed up by it's really weird
yep well got mixed himself by that
gogeta blue taser
one-on-one i think one-on-one kills
so i don't think three kills yeah i
don't think this goes either it was just
above the the spark me uh he's not a
limit break don't think this is gonna be
enough
wow
it's not done yet now
i am wondering if if one if one and two
would have killed you know i don't know
actually i think it would have but i've
been lying a lot and you know what the
thing i'm not lying about is the fact
that
he's going to be the one
moving to winners
final
off
the events today excellent play man
yeah yeah i think the first match was a
little bit more convincing that one went
down to the wire but
he showed that he's just got like a
a strong resolve right he went round
start jump back super dash yeah like he
did the most unpredictable thing and
like i said i think sheridan sometimes
gets
a little bit nervous when people are
very unpredictable and taser
is very unbelievable by his dragon rush
takes his dragon rush takes a very
consistent right everything else about
him is very hard to kind of gauge yeah
yeah definitely that's going to be a
super cool
winners final on this bracket so plug
took it to one against face identizer
took it to nil over sweden the plug
versus taser will be the winners final
later today but now let's jump towards
the loser side and from netherlands
representation with junks and nuestra
familia the winner of this will face
siridan and then it's rough shadow
against full telefury we know of this
facing face al dante so jugs you
mentioned him earlier we don't know
we've seen him in tournaments absolutely
wanted he won cbk uh been around stuff
nuestra familia the question mark of
this event
that's the best thing about events like
this right i remember like all
tournaments going who's this who's this
how far did they get and we've got this
in uh
the master team catch top eight
a player that not maybe not a lot of
people know about uh holding it down for
the netherlands the dutch community here
having to do a friendly fire though
against sharks which
it's kind of gotta feel bad but you've
gotta do what you you gotta do right
yeah and yeah they were playing a little
bit earlier
i saw a nick v stream and all i remember
is that they played uh bass vegeta
all right so it's blue goku
it's blue goku bass vegeta and ui goku
this this is
this team
sweat team
yeah that's uh any perspective at the
ready he's not here to mess about
uh
but on the other side here we got juts
with the uh kid buu kefla
yep that's uh one of these i mean kefla
is starting to see much much more uh
mileage
lately you know a character that
definitely won a lot during that patch
the first opening though goes to
investor familia
wow
oh but mr confirmed probably one of the
two m5m but didn't get the uh the legs
extended here
he got swinging we got swinging i love
it damascus let's go
all right oh that was a nice
that was a nice 2h
putting man down i'm just going to
extend as much as he can to maybe get a
level 3 no goes for the assist to delay
wake up though to get away from that
assist situation
and nice nuestra
command grab and that's the dead kid who
yeah utilizing that spark damage there
we go
one should be enough
[Music]
in the corner here kefla gonna flex
all right
level three
into some pressure on jerk sides trying
to
open that vegeta up and the empty jumpy
is gonna open him up he's going to go
for as long as he comes he can ui goku
assist is back
and he's just going to get you a goku in
that state
it is indeed like you said extended as
much as they could even got a bar out of
it to be
nice and efficient going into this 2v2
still got spark
on deck as well as the one bar
let's see if just can pull it out or
is he going to get you wide it looks
like he's getting you wide damascus yep
man up put him into the corner
chuck still got his part to work with
but there's no assist right now no point
in sparking
i should be a coach
i should i should i should sell
i should sell my my my wisdom someday
one day
sell your services sell your services i
mean jugs isn't out now but like you
said there wasn't an assist on decks of
the spark maybe just that pure fear
knowing the option from ui
and here we go
possibly regretting using that spot
so early let's see
oh gets away
let's see i guess the opening nice the
six edge to get the extension there
and jugs
it's going to get a level 3 situation
probably goes to ui goku's yes
okay
what's the pressure
hasn't got a bar to vanish in obviously
we've got the speed of ui
and just stays away
oh all right
yeah probably gonna go inside switch
over to combo
and sending him back to the corner
it's gonna be forced to block but
there's no assist right now
so i mean you know you know the thing
just just jump the flips bro
easy clap
thrown back into the corner though
jax is on the back foot right now
keeping the pressure on still forced to
block spent a ton of time blocking and
jug's looking for his own opening right
now
that was
all right
getting in with the blue goku to let you
iguo get that blue light black but great
conversion jugs keeps the hopes alive
not able to kill with this but maybe a
level three no decides to keep it for
staircase the six h opens him up
and jugs is able to not only kill him
but also start
with five balls
i think that makes it one touch on both
sides potentially right with the
that much mirror and
kefla with limit break
we're gonna find out right now you don't
have to wait for the next episode of
dragon ball z and i think that's that is
it that is it
the kefla come back is complete level
three four jugs hit him with the candy
cane
and that's gonna be one nil for jerks
despite us familiar looking
a bit more in control throughout the
match that kefla did the job
yeah i think you're spot on right with
the control uh but juxta had explosive
damage like we saw in that last
interaction just okay for me to kill i
need to hit this button cool i'm gonna
do this button confirmed it perfectly uh
and just brought it back each time when
they were looking like on the brink
right so
sometimes it might feel a bit
disheartening when you feel like you've
got that much control in the match and
you still lose but you have to go into
the next game thinking okay i just need
to be a little bit more optimal uh other
than that i think they're like quite
equally matched in a really sick match
so far
absolutely it's been a super super good
match let's see which
one of these do we move forward remember
this is losers so
you are playing your life
on tournament life right there and you
know that a lot of points are on the
line today
if you want to qualify for the original
finals in december this is where you
need to do it
there we go in comes the blue
good block seen it before
i never know what to say about command
grab that has a strike afterwards but i
can talk about that to hate being super
clean doesn't go for the start or go
through the basic damage
blocks a dive kick
blocks the vanish backs always
patience by jux and gets blessed with
the super dash hitting the teleport it's
gonna take this to the bank and cash out
let's see
level three wants to mix
okay
it's behind this so yeah he went for the
mt earlier
trying to go for a bit more and that 2h
was
violent
that is
running one way to describe it right
then you did it perfectly but right now
here we go the gumball time to block the
blocks
and great dragon brush there is not
ready and that lugoku is already down
jugs doing great job at keeping the
momentum
and yeah slipping out of their hands
very very slightly not having a spark or
a third individual on the squad but this
is basically ui two characters that can
definitely make the comeback but they
need to be here first
oh okay this is on go straightforward
one yep
these 2h have been cleaned
they yeah full commitment there's rings
on those two ages they know what's
coming they're going for it perfect
twice now and now we're getting the 5s
vanish to put them back in the corner
jux
i'm going to take you out the corner
with the side under switch thing i don't
know where he is but it's kefla she's
going wild gumball mix
6h again and he's gonna build that
second ball that should be a dead base
vegeta yeah it just goes for ui goku to
get a bit more damage into level one and
back to kid booby go
oh what
that shut up
oh don't you dare man
hey come back here oh he don't hide he
doesn't have a ball he cannot do go for
the snap anyway
so definitely a good idea let's see got
a corner position now familiar
all the challenge
side swap as well
of bars that should be dead no oh my god
does he have a safety hd with this
no he's got a snipe yeah okay oh i had
to vanish actually i i don't know if
this one is safe it might be
it might be
maybe from that height yeah
well it depends if he has to land before
he can block but we'll never know
because
faith vegeta is going to get taken out
this game leaving ui to
get rid of three cams and justice side
it's an uphill struggle but this is how
it starts right with a dragon flash
listen seven bars as well he's got all
of the money in the world but again
another drop not looking good
i'm sorry i'm looking for something
trying to use that 5l the right arm of
the forbidden one mix mix
no i'm not getting mixed i'm finishing
up
here we go back it away
blocks the 5s blocks the beam and jugs
is in now kefla swinging oh no
that's about timing
gave it away
charity gave him for sure like you said
just did it a little bit too early still
in blocks done and now sharks have a
character down leaving two though
you are on ui the mirror match
all right let's go for the full screen
playing the beam game
yeah jailing him into something a good
one just get away at what a2h jugs 2h
have been absolutely deadly this set he
was way too ready that his studio for
jerks he's gonna move forwards in this
loose bracket western familiar takes the
seventh place
like that two h was mad close as well
for super dash that wasn't like a mid
screen full screen super dash he did
sneeze into super dash and drugs was
ready so like you said
uh fully deserving of that win just
being
so clinical with the decision making
that too h and the ones with kefla yeah
they were they're out here so uh shout
outs to jugs making it through seventh
place uh familiar unfortunate but still
get some points yeah in their back
pocket so get some points get everything
you need you know like it's definitely
uh worked well for him today seventh
place and we see jugs he will face
surreydan later today and on the other
side of the loser's bracket he's gonna
be off shadow against full metal fury
and not enough today
i can't wait i can't wait uh full metal
likes to uh downplay themselves a little
bit i i want to know if he still plays
roshi because he was a roshi mane he
played roshi for a while he had like
roshi napa and zebraly i think was the
team for a while
yes yeah but
he really thought roshi was bad
uh his twitter timeline will tell you
that he didn't really like what they did
to roshi but
uh he went away for a little bit he must
calm down like chilled out uh powered up
by plug hopefully and now he's
rejuvenized and gonna bring hopefully
brings a roshi because i haven't seen
roshi in a hot minute no
no
yep he's playing
oh he's the end okay so tn is new so
napa points
with zebraly mead and tn behind okay all
right interesting wolfshadow is the
the team
uh yeah this team is kinda deadly man
he
have suffered i mean full metal
definitely suffered against this team
shout out to rmz and taz aka fish
uh they're like pioneers of this team
and shadow plays it very well as well
but wake up buttons
the plug
full metal classic it's never really
your turn just a social construct let's
look at the loops
what what the heck just happened
genius
oh just reflect and that sideman is not
there anymore don't think yeah not gonna
commemorate this time
that's it
nice
one on one
that plays goku when i finish the job
nope he's gonna need cell to finish this
one and that's a dead napa
outcome but it's okay because you're
still behind
yeah z bully is definitely here i know
full metal is known for his nappa but if
you go to his twitch
his his avatar he's brody he's about the
big bodies clearly and here we go
getting the grab
nice bait on the reflect
all right
one where's he gonna choose
all right goes for the slow one okay the
dragon was finished after that
yeah
makes sense oh yeah that was that yeah i
respect the spark because like you get
hit otherwise
float
and again
wow
[Music]
that 2h
actually hurt me
after doing his uh barrier as well
that was crazy
he's in the game he's back in it
oh against the opening now with tien
he's gonna be able to build some meter
with this one glasses just yet shows you
to lock him down
oh yo tawan
holding that plasma gets smugged for it
the train and shout out with the
resilience goes to the 2m and he gets
a combo
all right back in the corner probably
when i go
i think he should right
yeah
yeah level three gets a one-touch
situation
man was sweating flies
and fury should be able to not only kill
that that gohan but also switch to brony
yes no
oh i saw brodie
[Music]
that was the most goalie kick i've ever
seen in my life he took it
he took a 10-yard run up
that was sick
i was sick
yo
my mud runner
i was like i ain't playing football
today it's rugby i've got to drive that
one up man jeez
[Music]
mad like david beckham that was sick
that was a sick one david becker that's
johnny wilkinson
wrong sports
you're right
that was the thing
that went that he kicked that character
out of the stratosphere like that
character was gone from the character
select screen that was sick but uh yeah
that's where i think it's 12 frames i
think him and krillin are tied for the
quickest two edges in the game 12 frames
so a 12 or 13. but all i know is that
kick came out way too quick there was no
way you reacted to someone doing that
all right now pass start starts with the
two end there and that's right all right
gets a bit of a pressure point right now
nice guess the dragon rush that should
give him an opportunity to plant the
excitement and let him do his job
there we go the youngin i'm not talking
about tolhan
oh he defends it but you know what this
means it's just time to plant again
any second now oh no he's going for mix
and he gets it
yeah full metal not prioritizing
planning and actually going for the uh
the high low stuff wow
chris brown walter wolf i don't like
tohan
right
he's going to get
a
level 3 and there is a left right behind
this
oh you know what
i don't care you think i care
do you think i care about you about this
i am pressing buttons i am baiting the
spark and you know what time is it
behind the spot c4
it's time to go take a direction
pick a choice
oh no that was dropped that was
unfortunate the reset was dropped there
and guess who got cancelled at least to
get sell out
lucky because lucky he's lucky that fury
dropped his mix
yeah that was unfortunate i know what
that setup was i've played full metal so
i'm uh i know by muscle memory not my
visuals i just pray in all the direction
but yeah he definitely messed up the uh
the sad man
you just speak high or low that's all
like like don't you're not gonna react
to it anyway pick high or low or spark
of course if you're a spark and and
just believe in your decision that's all
you got is this napocon we're gonna kill
or is going to reset me one of the two
that's always an option but right now
brony getting put in the corner
shadow
putting the pressure guard cancel brings
in tien the crane style 2m whiffs but
he's not going to stop him from pressing
buttons here we go full metal putting
the offense on overhead
all right let's keep some more pressure
right now the broly assist is coming
back
shadow's defense has been all right
against the mid against the pressure
that's trying to get them he goes for a
spark there i am surprised that in a
team with two such two such good anchors
he would decide to go
for a spark kill there
maybe he really dislikes torhan maybe
and i i think the tn's fairly new so you
might not have the optimal stuff so
maybe it's just about con
convenience right knowing that shadow's
not got their spark just do it
all right
oh no
these two ages are out here damascus
you are denied from staying in the air
stay in the ground please level one
into level one and fury is one character
away from moving forward in this losing
brackets
[Music]
okay but this is base two and seven bars
on deck
good blocks
oh that's a 5h
keeping it easy simple gets away all
right you've got a ton of bars so you
know one thing of course with the base
cool is ankle basically is too touch any
time
goes for the vanish just to get the
corner
this is not a thing right no that's a
mixtape mix that's a mix that's a mix
[Laughter]
he tried to go for the big bread mix i
guess
i have no idea what he went for man
i have absolutely no idea
he wanted him to maybe block the level
three and then go to do something from
like weird stuff i don't know
the stress
like literally is this the me i've never
seen before
all right he's going to get another
chance here though he's a knock down
this time goes for kerr ken uh abandon
the spirit box
i have i have no idea did you forget she
was playing bass goku
like like legit like i think i think he
did he was just like oh let me level
three now oh
he's getting conversion there somehow
but all right let's go
you know what it's pretty much a one
touch for workshop as well anyway so
yeah it's my favorite
shadow
that was
convincing enough full
metal fury will be the one
moving forward
in that loses brackets two-nil
for fury excellent play
and he will
still be alive on this and both shadow
will be taking a seventh place on this
tournament big ggs to him still a chance
we still have tunas in this topic
i mean
i'm i'm a fan of it i've always liked
that but i've always liked that like
from
back in the days and when it stays on i
i played napa and i was like he's he's
too technical for me and then full metal
plug here we are in the top eight
doing me proud man doing all the nappers
around the world proud i'm sure the
discord is popping off right now they
probably got their own like stream
watching parties
is like one of the the best places
around you know to be if you uh
if you want to uh to have some fun uh
you go on the napa discord and you will
you'll see it's a lot of fun everyone is
looking for more and more mixes everyone
is having uh fun looking for the dumbest
way to open your open on top and you
know they're trying but as i said right
like same for me like i was trying to uh
to learn napa napa is a
it's a try hard he's a tryhard character
like you need to be a
you need to be a try hard
and to spend a ton to invest a ton of
time on your napa for him to be good
he's especially now he's an excellent
character now but he's not a character
you're gonna just pick up and play he's
a character i have to pick up design a
team around him design a game plan
around him and learn a billion different
conversions combos mixes and stuff
he's a part-time job yeah
now alone is a part-time job and then
you gotta learn two other characters as
well uh hopefully they're two characters
that you already play but yeah nappa's
uh it looks it looks easy because
they're just doing the same combo into
plant but there's a lot of uh intricate
details in that uh which we're going to
see more of going from full metal back
to winner side man like
plug is up next
uh going up against taser and we're
gonna uh that would be for later
fighting remember we win losers
quarterfinals for now losers want you
it's going to be sweden against drugs
again playing their tournament life
playing their tournament life
in that loser's bracket to access that
top four
for sure sorry about that c3 moment oh
c4 demoted c3
oh let's see some damage right now here
we go go gr
sure dan taking it to jacks
i'm
i'm
sure these players play quite a lot uh
online ranks i haven't seen it for a
while but i know i've seen this on one
of their streams before so
let's see if we're going to see any like
players specific tech against each other
yeah
let's see
the pressure oh
okay he still got the instant air dash
that was a good
one and he could have punished that one
the dragon rush could have been punished
but jerk was not ready and surrey that's
gonna extend that convoy that should be
no more spark gets the opening excellent
one can you kill that kid the assist is
coming back the second bar is there
yeah very smart very smart yeah making
sure he's got either insta kill or a
powerful level one on deck in the
background oh level three
brings him back in though
nice thing full stream gets the super
dash
nice one
bit too hard for the normal confirm yeah
it goes for the simple stuff there i
like that not taking any risk and he's
getting the
the most mid mix of all time
and again a little bit too high for the
air to ground conversion but cashes out
the three bars there we go
i'm sure then margarine juxta in this
corner right now won't let them out only
when he knows he can mix them and there
we go
golgi is doing work today
instead nice one so redone is uh looking
angry to be in losers brackets
you're not wrong
supernatural assist everything by the
kitchen sink being thrown at jokes
oh he's telling you i go oh i heard you
have a good combo let me let me let me
let me show you mine
oh no you could have punished that
yeah that's an unfortunate whiff there
with the m we know he's got the reigns
but vertically
not the one right now oh no i don't know
if he went in five end and not six
[Laughter]
listen i don't know if surya has a train
to take or something to do after after
the event but
he's not wasting any seconds
he's like i've gotta play more imagine
now i'm in losers all right okay cool
let's get this over and done with give
me back the taser yeah uh but yeah very
clinical again we saw the staircase
combo that he pulled out there right at
the end uh true dan not here to mess
about hopefully jux or the dutch players
and give him your energy he's gonna need
it because yeah uh
this is
angry art yeah he's the he's the final
dutch representative as well right
yeah yeah gotta be careful uh i think
these are the moments when you can kind
of open up sheridan because he's so
aggressive but you have to be ready for
it and if you're like how he won't do
that that's crazy like why would you do
that that's when he would do it yeah
absolutely but let's see so rodan is uh
looking completely unchallenged so far
in this match up let's see if again some
more and opens him up with the classic
double dash but no conversion i
[Music]
you can turn it around here
just talking him down against the
opening regardless that was probably
done trying to escape trying to jump
away i'm not entirely sure but
chucks fails to kill him the dash block
into an amazing command grab there very
early on to surprise him until i get a
chunk of damage with that level three
power level one into
cheetah
yeah party poppers being a party pooper
bringing in beta gr
and here we go strings oh watch the
combo he's got these under pressure
we've got these i mean it usually does
but not today
yeah
let's see send one down
goes all the way down to level three he
wants the leaks behind us
interesting
i feel mostly sure than save spark but i
thought my man is kind of important
getting new ways the guard can still
walk got to watch out oh he gets the hit
but no conversion just yet regardless
have you seen my neutral i have not i do
don't take buttons and i get my own deal
damage
indeed and that
should be a dead go gr
that is not good that is a very big
component of the shoe dance team
and vote for ui goku to finish this one
chugs
taking the leading characters but sweden
still good spot
oh wow we've punished that was sick
how much can you get with this
goes for a simple one watch out or good
reflect on the assist but regardless
gets opened by the 2l
it's a completely different match but
you know what
tien will spark
now jugs have to do the comeback
[Music]
can he survive
punish that look
one touch
oh my god that was massive brain
what a beast
that was the biggest brain
flips i have seen in a while no one's
avoiding it no one's avoiding that one
that's crazy i'm a fan i'm a fan
let him know right yep
let him know
all right and now all three characters
are in one touch situation
one
last one down like you said still got
spark on deck three bars anything right
now like if you open kefla up into spark
you're gonna bring the tone of meter
regardless and get the kill or straight
to spark regardless that has to cover
himself up got to watch out jugs you've
got two blocks one
it's not gonna be killing just yet
because the command grab
here we go you said it you said this was
a jux come back on the table right now
it's looking like it's not gonna happen
he is hanging in the air trying to hit
him with a two three six
volleyball slide in
oh hello
what is happening it's movement
whoa oh he's a hot spark anymore all
right jones oh five h can he kill
with this kid who is not the biggest
damage character he has to yell at him
and put him in one touchy
[Music]
what do you do then
chucks where you going good blogs
gets this one regardless and jugs is
gonna move to one one
denies that comeback
from siridan a pretty hard one
to take it through that as honestly like
he had all the tools in the world with
the fully spark tien versus uh kid buu
alone but drugs
clutches it gets the win
and that is going to be jugs
staying alive in that tournament it's
one one
you weather the storm right which was
the spark tien the the
the fact of that can catch anyone and i
think at the last moment uh sheridan
went for the volleyball slide to get the
armor but wasn't quick enough and we see
jux take that making it last game from
both players loser is going to be out of
the tournament
who has got the momentum right now he's
going to take it away he's looking like
it's going to be jugged as he is
you know what if there was an advantage
there i think that might be the killing
combo
wait what what huh
i think he was right out of the
effective range
tomorrow's stream's going to be a
madness oh that's all i'm saying that's
going to be unclipped on
that stream
oh no what is happening c4
what is happening
hopefully sure that's going to get this
golgi around put him in the back maybe
let's see
there we go
he needs to bring this back he needs to
keep his compulsion don't get mad the
game might be against you but dragon
rushes will always save you as he takes
out the kid boo
close to match damascus very close ryden
already out of spark anyway so uh let's
not rule drugs out at all kefla goku is
a very very strong shell
oh my god we don't block this
active defense
i'm just very active defense there and
that's scary to do with base fuji are
not having the longest normals forces a
spark out here from jugs can now
he gets hit with the overhead is super
hard to see behind the beam there he's
going to survive but does drugs go for
uh hells on oaky let's find out
all right
yeah level three he wants the guaranteed
one and no reflect for anything
you've got to pick a choice sorry don't
wake up you don't have spark
not too much you want a situation
decided to reflect on that reflect he's
punished
jugs could not build that bar no
no he's not
you're still alive
oh that's okay another mix then
another one another one two
characters to two
can't call it a little bit uh more alive
than juxta side but that can dissipate
in a split second knowing that your
problem
but
surprise surprise
surprise
let's go for this one sending
as much damage as he can go for the
assist and level three it's fuzzy city
oh he actually take that that was that
was real
that was wrong he tried to go through
the oh my god
the brains are expanding evil
oh she was an airport
back to neutral for a split second
doesn't get to confirm of the assist
there
oh he's looking to jump in there with
the kept like a scene
they both had to try
they both had to give you a try man
reflect punish
the punish
and it's the only one
ui tian the cei
tien with three bars so he's not gonna
he's gonna even like the two openings
there watch out
solid one oh my god big 2h massive
damage gonna come up right now how much
does he want to give though because he's
just gonna extend to the max
i got the damage he gets from the trade
it's kind of ridiculous man one touch
he doesn't really need a super at this
point i think he's killing him with a
normal bnb but he needs to get the hit
trying to slide into the dm's
man's taken though all right
level
level three of course not the strongest
mix of all time after that level three
but three done the defense is on your
side right now the ball on jugs cam
jumps
at the offense goes for this and you
know what who needs mix
dragon russia's mix
[Music]
got hit with the classic
the classic vanished into dragon ross
the last thing
sheridan was looking for and i mean it
is ui right there's so many options he
has uh from when he knocked you down
especially mid-screen all the flips and
the same side buses and the plus frames
you're scared of so much and they're in
the headlights
jugs pulls it back and that last game
was looking kind of scrambling at the
end i think the nerves will get into
both the players
but shouts and jugs clutches it man yeah
choice clutching it and jugs remains the
final
dutch representative for this one after
taking it 2-1
over through the an excellent play uh by
jokes reading taking that fifth place
for today a couple of points in his
pocket one more game remain before we
move to the first two three territory
and this one
is going to be face al dante
versus full metal fury we've seen both
of these guys playing we've seen the
face that looked good but dropped a
couple of stuff and a fury who is well
playing his game
yeah if you've seen the previous games
you definitely know these uh players
wrong form obviously fazel losing it to
plug and he's probably thinking damn
i've gotta go from one napper to another
great but that might bode well for him
you know having that bit more uh matchup
experience going into full metal
but full metal every scene plays a
different type of napa not very focused
on just always doing sub and he's happy
to go for the high low and stuff like
that and stagger pressure so
let's see if he can crack open fazel's
defense with that pressure absolutely
looking forward to
this one full metal fury player one
still with the napa team of course he's
gonna face faisal dante and he's
classic he's zamasu
you know he's known for that zamasu he's
known for the damage that he gives them
and this team you mentioned it earlier
is it's an extremely optimal team face
al dante has got like tods sparklers
tods for two bars with this team
yep
yeah like
if the root i mean i've seen him do uh
he's got a super dash spark confirmed
tod i know he's got dr
tod with zamasu with that spark he's got
a keyblasteody
yeah like
if you get hit with like an ied light
that's probably the only time you don't
ever think he could kill me like
anything else he hits you
oh my god
why
god get absolutely clubbed what the hell
no he dropped
not like this
and the spark is gone as well and that
might come back to buy him
he's holding out fairly well so far oh
yeah you can't approach a man like that
here we go and he's going to get the
kill not in the way he wanted
but you've got to take what you're given
right it's okay
it's going to be just a bit more
literally used but at least he gets it
my god
no messing about full metal is trying to
get to plug asap but files will die
probably a little bit
aware now of the threat that's on the
table
all right trying to get something with
that now passes but no
zebraly oh no no one cares about your
barrier five about the swords
light him up oh you're going for the new
stuff
he does okay
because i don't even know what just
happened
[Music]
i i kind of so full mails told me how
why that hit and i don't want to tell
that one it's actually really stupid
you have to go follow him on twitter and
you'll give your answer or maybe i'll
just plug if he's feeling generous but
that makes i feel is the second worst
the second strongest one other than the
mid-screen money can do
that was gross
oh my god the explosion re-stands is
always one of my favorite to watch it's
it's always it's always this i see
rapper players in chat being like
literally just whole block like like
like there is no other option in the
world you know chill oh my god oh my oh
wow that's not hilarious that he's not
funny brody versus yamcha no one's
laughing no one's having a good time
damn full metal running a train through
faisal someone tell him just block bro
don't hold up otherwise you get hit by
the salmon that's literally all you have
to do don't hold up
just hold your grounds
i just read in the chat here i just read
it in the chat
it's actually not a good mix
i mean it's getting him top eight
did it hit
who was that in chat
i'm going to find you and say you play
fazel see if you can mix them
like did it hit
yes so it's mixed
why do you want to judge the quality of
a mix that opened the open on top
you know
oh my god no
all right
trying to escape
good reflect but face alden tasted
pressing buttons
yeah he committed to pressing buttons so
oh my god
oh fiori
living up to his name he is swinging and
he's gonna be able to take out this
zamasu as long as he can get into the
super which he does
fury is kind of out there right now man
[Laughter]
oh yeah
yeah oh okay okay okay
i mean that first game going really
quick maybe not realizing this is
potentially last game
no got punches for you we hold raw tank
fury is in max confidence mode right now
i can't see your thing
we neither but you know what pardo can
punch through it let's get to this one
level three
keeping some pressure behind this siri
forced to block he's gonna block he's
gonna reflect oh
none of them we get we block with our
face
again opened up i don't know if he's
gonna get enough power to
hear him that should be enough i mean
this is yamcha it's not the best level
one
pain oh my gosh yeah it's time to stop
playing skeleton oh never mind okay it's
okay it's a gem
okay oh my god oh my god oh my god
i'll be able to snap him if you want
wow
active defense
and you know what's coming
you know what time is it
my god that was an amazing answer i am
surprised the anti-reflex string was not
on point for
uh you know on the formula 3 side but
that's okay we take those into level 3.
okay and five is doing some very like
yamcha pacific stuff
so yeah maybe the full urbi uh
confidence and knowledge of the
characters way better than picking
someone stronger because right now fouls
will bring in this back he was a
character down now he's leveled by way
more health in his character sides
not enough powers though to get any kind
of kill so you're gonna have to play
that uh
probably life oh my god
you try to reflect there
not not today man
not today against napa in oh no another
drop no two h on this one there's a
chance for face aldante to kill that
broly and the sixth seven is all he's
gonna take
six and just enough damage they're
taking out the big boy broly leaving
napo on his own oh no
just
trust auto combo
just why did you have to fight at this
you just had to do five lln
just
that is all you needed
but instead you get the win to face al
dante and i feel like
i can't see face identity right now
but i can see the sweat like entering
through the forehead
okay
one down one to go
this the master this is team this could
happen to you twice it's got napa and
broly it could definitely happen to you
twice yeah and if that doesn't succeed
tn just might clip you and you just
explode yeah so
this this team is you're always on the
edge of your seat going again because
you could lose at any moment yeah team
stress final game before we get into
that that uh
top four and first two three territory
and we open up with a pretty
conservative start none of them really
taking a risk we're flying around and
good movement from this alternative what
is the sovereign idea damascus i don't
know if it's gonna play a factor as long
as fargo keeps this corner position it
should
piss the tape yeah he's probably gone by
now
all right you're supposed to block great
take
high fury and he had committed to
something but looking version by facile
dante there oh go you know once again i
think five la would have caught that
zamasu
but you know what excellent play by
facetime because he's gonna kill nappa
[Music]
i mean that's a good start right nine
nine problems but nappa is not one
anymore as he takes him out
but
in comes the bully chest day every day
oh you know what see this key blast up
the gym
opening for face out that is going to
put him in the corner
when does it start combo so sick yeah
i got hit
i don't know about you
press one chad if you've got this
absolutely you never expect someone like
z-body to
like slip and slide his way around you
like that that's the last thing you're
gonna be seeing
that was me t taken to the butcher's
sparks and gets away he wants space
great conversion by face al dante ooh
the momentum is fully on face outside
right now he's gonna get a ton of meter
to build with this how much can he get
one three
you tried
you tried something a bit too big brain
for that moment for him to pray to not
press some buttons got to watch out
you're in the corner now full metal fury
forced to block and the guard canceled
in comes another wow
bardock is so fast he's faster than four
like he couldn't use the telekinesis
he's actually faster than four that's
crazy
but duke
in with the javelin
starting to look very good for dante
that's another opening
he's still in the middle of territory
but she should build that ball and that
should be a dead tien and now it's
looking extremely long for fury
it is it is i mean it is the broly but
the resources aren't really there right
no spark only three bars and
fazel's got almost a full
squad this is how it starts though
i hope a dream and a bully in the back
it could happen to you it could happen
to anybody it oh my god
have you seen
the width of these shoulders do you
think an assist is going to worry this
he actually just brushed off water ducks
back
zee bully and now zamasu the characters
he's one character away and it's yamcha
oh my god
c4 i'm scared come on call an adult
hold on i don't guys i'm um
oh shields up oh you shoot you shoot up
you should have come and grabbed after
that uh
can i get two h that was smart oh
it's happening
he's dead
no can't kill this doesn't kill yeah
yeah okay
i chest damascus i can't
oh my goodness it happened
it actually happened
a hulk a freight and a bully in the back
that is all you need
that's all you need
full metal fury
from losers damascus is hiding
i just don't want to see it but you have
to you have to embrace this character
man z bully
that's a legendary super saiyan i can't
lie man i can't lie what a comeback
like
it's i think i think faisal got kinda uh
like victim of his own maybe impatience
because he had
it's frustrating to face liberally in uh
in anchor position right it's extremely
frustrating so
seeing this
seeing zebraly starting to really really
put some pressure on it really really
makes it hard
really makes it hard to keep composure
and there we go we got our top four
all
sorted in winners we're gonna have plug
versus
taser
in losers we're going to have
jugs the last touch representative
versus
full metal fury it is
an absolutely ridiculous top eight so
far
and two napa's in top eight c4
that's uh yeah two numbers in top four
is uh really sick and i mean it's kind
of egg on my face because i definitely
fall first for sure that would have got
over
and and look we are right full metal jux
holding it down for the dutch is a
it's gonna be crazy two nappers top four
only eu man
top four is on is up next guys but we're
gonna take a very quick five minutes
break back in five minutes with more
dragon ball fighters all first to three
to know which one will be bagging 200
points and a solid option towards the
offline finals that will happen early
december today will be plug will be
taser will be full battlefury or will it
be jugs we will know that after the top
four five minutes break get a drink get
a snack and we'll be back with more
banging dragon ball fighters here for uh
the europe to master events get a good
snack and a good drink because you know
the next games are gonna be sick see you
guys in five minutes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Music]
is
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
my
[Music]
what is good guys
ladies and workers boys and boomers we
are back with top four of the ten
catching master online series there has
been a roller coaster of results coming
in
uh we are gonna get into top four i
believe is gonna be the same as uh all
the other tournaments top three be first
of three it's all good it's all first to
three it's all first three all of all of
top four we only have first we only have
first two threes now
big games
big games coming up now for that top
four and i mean
napa you know we got plug in windows
final against tazer
and then we got jugs the last touch
representative of the tournament about
to face full metal fury it is a uh it is
a big
big top four because of course this is
four points and it is a four ton of
points for the master challenge 200
points for the first 150 points for the
second 100 for the third and the fourth
gets 70 points and i've got to say uh if
like if you want to qualify to this
regional finals
my personal belief is a top two of the
master events
is
almost necessary maybe thirds but i
think outside of thirds you would need
the winner to not enter any other
tournament so you can grind points in
the meantime but you know that whoever
wins today and whether it's plug taser
like any of these four they're gonna
grind every single tournament there are
quite a few uh coming up on as good as
dragon ball in i believe it's two weeks
uh for uk one of the the europe two uh
events and a lot of events for everyone
to be there if you want to run your own
event of course you can do exclamation
wc and go to the drawable fighters
portal sign up apply and put your
tournament in if you want to be a player
you can enter it's one week is next week
nick v thank you so much for next week
with the regent and plenty of
tournaments on every single region as
for this channel guys every single
weekend until november you will have
some action next week is going to be the
japanese master events
in two weeks is
east coast master event and in three
weeks it's going to be
the
french
like the sorry in three weeks is the
spain one so spain portugal and italy
and in four weeks is the france belgium
and switzerland one so every single
weekend we're gonna have some big boy
events and then in december
it's going to be offline dragon ball
fighterz hits
i'm looking forward to this man for the
finals but the players already in that
lobby it is going to be plug versus
taser in the first two three
to go in grand finals
winners we have seen plug winning winner
stays on the london offline two weeks
ago uh he's fresh off a couple of wins
in tournaments he won another one over
yasha a week before online and today
he's looking to add another win as for
taser i do not think taser has won a
tournament before but he's got plenty of
top three under his belts
yeah he's come very close i know uh the
the uk like uh
basically not more tough for the uk side
but he came second after uh jake wise uh
but he's been a very strong player right
i mean plug is one of his trainer
partners they used to play a lot on
parsec in the end in the secret dojo
so they know what they're both about
right uh pizza has really strong defense
i say that i say that
it's dragon rock at the start of the
game but don't make me look like a liar
thank you
i feel like that it'd be like you can't
have invincible defense you know the
mother no matter who you are it's okay
oh trying to vanish that is not going to
work and plug is just waiting for the
gojita oh gesture assist at least
then you've got a confirmer for that
speaking of confirms dark you can vanish
good stuff plug looking like he's on a
tear once again going up against taser
can anyone stop this guy
oh my god he's gonna spark i you know
what i don't think sparking there was a
good idea because he can't kill the hits
and i think regardless he would have
gotten the same amount of damage
without spark i don't think he realized
he would kill vegeta so
quickly you still have a few seconds of
spark to play with but good reflect by
taser
yeah i agree there wasn't much life on
the point character to get enough damage
on the hit maybe you went straight to
supers that might have done something
but you're definitely right maybe that
spark ill advise but
the lead is still very strong for plug
oh here gosh the movement the awareness
the spacing is all working out for plug
as he gets taser on his last character
and
the game feels like he's just five yep
taser with the spark he's waiting he's
trying to be patient plug has the full
team right now first opening goes to
taser
this is what he's gonna need to mount
this comeback still with sparkle
me tease
me elves
already right didn't confirm it and just
went for a dragon rush but it does here
oh no oh get stuck in all right
what do we go for do you have the
mid-screen one do you have your screen
mixed with this yeah
yep yep yep
oh my god he tried to pay the spark that
was actually big brain because that
would have made you the spark uh but
tazer decided not to spark there giving
him another chance
i got deleted my irl lifebar went down
brother i completely guess wrong
of course oh it had to be done because
he's in this park anyway and he's
getting his own opening that was a very
deep jump hill and he's gonna get the
kill with this plug
is looking extremely
strong today dab
that idle look like a hit center brother
i don't i upload hitbox i'm not looking
i play ground blue i'm not blocking it
bro like it just hits it now it just
hits it now there's no way
let's see that plug looking very good
taser needs to get back to it really
quick of course
all of this is the first two three so a
bit more time
for taser to bring it but
plug is on the tail
you've said about the accolades that
he's got in the last couple of events
he's entered who's stopping this guy
it's looking difficult man
it's definitely looking long at the
moment but let's see oh my god open oh
my god
happy birthday to you i no
not going for the best one yeah he's
gonna snap your eye anyway
yeah i'm not sure where you had cooking
with that uh that route
he's has he like assimilated some of
yash's tech
this is young
this is young plug
we're talking about no spark
no blocking just vibes
the good strong vibes yeah and again
look how cool plug is getting this lead
on taser
oh he's clapping
but no one's here to give him an encore
but the sad man is uh he tried he tried
to fight this this watch i'd steal that
oh my god oh the sandwich oh the
sandwich
subways would you give himself a pencil
the business partner c4
the business partner always always
delivers
10 out of 10 bro the beam goes over the
cyberman yep leave reviews need reviews
five stars let's go oh it's free
it's like
[Music]
all
you need right you gotta get the corner
and you've gotta make it hurt as much as
possible probably gonna bring a hit with
a level three here we go hands up in
chat
let's see if tayden can make this
comeback
that's gonna be hard
good box oh no that's nice you can block
that
dead
you're getting the power the hands are
rising
they hit
yeah i'm about to say i think we're
going to see if they hit 5h
star of the combo yeah it's going to be
massive damage and there you go it is
out leaving gogeta
of the blue variety to try and make this
battle of the comeback
none of them hits good block
uh
questionable but okay
interesting frame trap oh computer
punish
unfortunately okay okay he was on that
side i guess
we take this all right sending him the
corner
oh nice one tap into this are you gonna
try it
the fake the fake mix
that was
ryan that's so smart that was so smart
big ups big off the table there but it's
not over our base coupe
is in the building oh jumping
oh my god what
trying to make it happen
oh no no it's one touch i'm not sure
what taser was looking for in this one
probably didn't go for the right come on
plug
unfortunately caught in the bad habits
of jumping and back dashing and that is
something you see a lot right
something you see a lot from the ton of
players is
it's movement
but
unsafe movement when you're that close
going for an airdash would pretty much
lose to any of the offensive
decisions
from your opponents and taser is going
to take this one
plug looked good but taser immediately
closes the gap it's 1-1 and this was
just three
yo me and chat we're gonna get roy some
taser later that was because we put our
hands up we kept the belief
kept the belief right we made it happen
go gear blue corp plug slip in and
finally someone is showing a true [ __ ]
in his armor
it's gonna be difficult to keep going on
this but
let's see one one in this one is final
plug versus taser
we are guaranteed to close match now
yeah yeah 100 okay
and let's see if taser can get like a
good start because both games they would
went a bit better shape for him right
for the happy birthdays let's see if he
doesn't get half a birthday that he's
actually in this game
not sure i forgot about the early happy
birthday as well let's go
simple grab put man down
and go to a chart but yeah good
reflector ah the dragon was gonna
oh
drop the combo
oh and he gets clipped by the assist but
not ready for the confirm blocks the
elbow
and the cross up okay
taser right here being a plumber
blockages
it's a
he
and look what he gets for it look at the
rewards
he looks fun to
should come back on time to overheat the
mix
what's the mix yep there we go speaking
of assists
what's better hit your sideman
oh i'm maybe somebody
make you sad for me
let's go another one another one another
one another oh one attack what attack by
taser i can't not believe he was ready
enough for this one
jeez
then you don't sleep from this guy
defense man said oh you're trying to run
this back with me he said i don't i
don't subscribe to deja vu but i don't
even see him once
[Music]
oh he's dead i think if you optimize
that combo that's dead yeah that's an m
star
doesn't even go for anything longer than
necessary
one one and one
and that is going to be a dead ui goku
plug looking better
he yep yep for sure for sure taser still
got spark and last time he had these two
characters didn't make the comeback
as long as he doesn't get himself in
those sticky situations again
nicely over the five esto
taser keeps the offense a putting plug
in the corner what's gonna be on this
tap tap dr
oh
fishing with the two hates but no one's
there plug
making his move
taser stop him in these tracks good
cross up car side swap so he's gonna
have to take him to the mid oh no he's
gonna go for advantage okay interesting
to get the opening and that should be a
dead baseball court that's an amazing no
highlight
all the blocks of spark this is all
right the mask this is what you've got
wow put your hands
man put his hand in his pocket what you
got for me
coming in right now there's a blue
record in the back
like
my goals
call an ambulance
but not for me
i'm on the driver's seat man
oh my gosh he takes off and getting hit
by the l taser smells blood and he goes
for the momentum stay same side with an
empty vanish probably wasn't ready
that's why they block it that was a dark
drug
and that should be a dead local blue and
you know what
now
this is one of the things right
napa
has a lot of tools but
one of the weakness of anyone who plays
napa is
putting napa last
one of your strategies if you play a
solid napa player would be to try
and get napa without spark lust
because he will rely on having a chance
to plan the cyberman
and a great tech so this time my plug he
knew that the cyberman would save him
business partner
so so this is the hard because it's
round start
plug has got enough bars to do like a
guard council vanish into plant that's
probably not the safest way nappa can
plant in neutral against someone like
hate the super dash and ronaldinho is
going to stop him but the anti-air
confirmed hazel might not give him that
chance he's got four bars it's going to
go for the he's not done
oh no he's getting this one
how do you kill with this
i don't think he can kill but
he can plot
level three oh yeah because he didn't
have his bounce he couldn't go over it
like a dragon though yeah yeah yeah but
that's okay that's a high low now it's a
high note i know
you know what it's neither high nor no
it's a dragon rush and plug clutches the
comeback on this one two one what it six
in winners final man jeez
you know what i was so sick because
tazer went for the uh ex ronaldinho but
that's only strike invincible it's not
throw invincible yeah
plug knows what he's doing even without
saving plugged in with nappa he knew who
you but yeah he definitely clutched it
out uh and can i park we've been saying
it's not easy to do that it's actually
not easy yeah yeah it's not easy but if
someone can pull it off he's definitely
one of napa specialists
with blog two one one game away for him
to go on grand finals wins winner sides
okay taser don't let that get to you man
you had that in the bag but it happens
sometimes you just gotta keep composed
and just do it again and clutch out this
time let's see
this is not how you do that yep
absolutely not
bringing him down there's another assist
to ensure mixed one but you know what
we don't block
in this
household advised man
no one's got time for blocking we're
trying to get points out here
oh my god just to edge the flips bro
oh
extensions we've got weaves out here
let's go get them knocked down there's a
free plant
that's what
watch out
combo breaker
the beast
at this point it's not just a business
oh my god look at this it's a wingman
it's a wingman he's covering you
at all times oh it's not working let me
let me come and support my boy
that's it you met you guys met at work
and friendship happens
yo there is a
there's going to be some memes there
can't wait to what people do on mss pain
i want to see cybermen with suits you
know
the contract has been signed oh he tried
to go for the optimal and instead of
this it's napa getting his own opening
and that should be a ton of damage more
than enough to get the kill on that goku
yeah i think he's gonna be one-on-one
maybe not even three months you need to
oh yeah this should be
yeah come on that's enough let's go who
blew in and
plug is already looking good in this
winner's final two characters away from
the grand finals winner's position
yeah i think taser
especially from the last match he's
gonna be scared of the uh the power
family man mapper and the kids oh yeah
maybe doing bits oh yeah
these ones have definitely worked a ton
and taser is looking for a way not
trying to take frisk of course he can't
retake this great air to a conversion
[Music]
yeah as soon as that base crew a was off
the table
taser took his chance
the 2m doesn't work the ronaldinho gets
blocked
oh my god imagine a command grab that
also covers the wii
i couldn't
couldn't beat imagine
oh no didn't finish his plate though
he scared the combo away the masses the
power's too strong
heard the loops like nope we're not
happening today plug manages to get this
one good reflect by taser he's gonna be
forced to block but not oh my god the
floats oh no
ah take your way
away
el clasico
the throwback two m's in the building
and taser on his last character hit
something
i know a few hit players do not like as
long as we said about napa being
anchored by here
it's rough and he gets mixed napa asus
helping that blue there the masters i
think it might be one more hit and plug
is going to go
similar to grand finals
one touchy
gonna have to block great take that
plugs defense is looking extremely solid
in his final right now and the na passes
no conversion watch out for the base
cool oh we got the opening there but no
conversion and you know what another
backhand swat and plug
he's going to take the win 3-1 in this
winner's final
extremely
convincing performance pipeline
a lot of work to do by
taser now to bring it back in losers and
maybe offer himself
even back
yeah uh
man like shout out to taizo he didn't as
good as he could that last the the game
before last
so close to making it 2-2 but
like you said the napa master showing
napa mastery right that's that's all it
is and plug continues his tear in dragon
ball fighterz making his way to grand
finals so he can sit and
you know see who was going to come and
challenge him for the number one
headband is it going to be juxt full
metal or taser we are going to find out
who is going to go against taser first
full metal fury versus jux
versus the uk
i heard you like napa well we are
getting some more napa right now and
that is going to be full with fury
facing jugs
in losers an important place on losers
final to transfer live get as much
points as uh they can but of course i
want to talk about plug right now right
so
we've seen how good plug has been lately
he's he's finally broken the curse like
plug has been known as a resident choke
artist right like a lot of times i was
like oh plug one let me go get a drink
and then i come back and plug it loses
bracket you know but the curse is slowly
but truly being lifted and right now
not only is he sitting on grand finals
winner side he's sitting against three
players he's already beaten more than
once in tournaments
and this is actually a very difficult
trap
because it's very easy
to be overconfident right now thinking
ah done these three i've beaten before
i'll beat them in grand finals and get
surprised so
need to keep the composure to the max
and treat it as you being the challenger
to finish this one but before that of
course
losers semi-final is going to be full
metal fury
versus jugs canned drugs
keep flying the netherlands scholars
one more time and still represent the
country or will hipski not hipski
i keep it keep scared i'm like i'm going
to say hipster at some point i did shout
out to man will fury
guarantee a top three a uk top three
let's go first to three yeah like you
said he's got a long way to do that he's
got a few jokes and then takes a very
strong player but right now he's gonna
have to deal with this kid boo
and he's doing all right and you know
what i'm pretty sure there's a lot of uh
deniers not even uh non nappa players a
lot of nappa players are like right why
you got another one playing that's
that's not what we do here
there's nothing you haven't got the uh
the authority in the discord to be
playing that front plane
oh my god
okay
okay
[Music]
spark raw tank so many options here for
jugs
oh okay
active frames
looking like a geo
that is caught no bro tag allowed the
drugs keeps the pressure on
and sends a broly down
who is the knockoff berserker man this
is broly
it is kefla this is the eternal battle
junk so far is putting in work versus z
this is actual imposter syndrome right
here on screen
kefla going to get that knock down
though
a lot smaller than broly so he's got a
lot more to deal with when it comes to
defensive vr behind the beam is not
going to work obviously because of the
block stein and full metal takes
advantage gets out escapes
and says have you got a film kepler no
you don't hold this
i got three of them i've got three of
them
i mean two i'm sorry i got two of them
the third one doesn't exist i don't know
yeah yeah yeah it's like it's
imaginary anyway okay flower right now
putting the pressure building a ton of
meter
but it's done decay betraying her
gosh i'm good punish did you see full
mail just walked away goes i know you
want a dash of the grand i've got you
you haven't got combos though you might
have to work on those full metals now
kefla in cross are blocked
and not the overhead oh my gosh she is
the bulls mission
yeah these 6h have been really opening
full metal fury up
and that's tien down
napa in with a zebra behind or he wanted
to plant but it's not happening and
that's going to be a dead nap as well
jugs
making excellent work
right now of his opponents
which is very solid and comfortable
yeah he's definitely just
holding down for his uh for the dark
community right now going through a lot
of plays in loser's side making it work
against ball metal
who who beat fosu earlier don't forget
oh my gosh talk to him
let them know
it's looking long another mix blocked
after blocking like three mixes in a row
this is what you could add to
this has got to be paid man
man bandit i'm out he's
2m
it happens it happened
i was thinking how poetic would it i'm
gonna use try and use my uh shoutcaster
powers how epic would it be
if full metal
got to grand finals and v plug
the only way you can beat plug is to
play that [ __ ] that is that is the key
that is too much that that would be
scripted let me check the script
i'm going to ask uh mothership what the
script you see
is that how it goes down
let's see how this goes oh opens the
dragon rush and jerks once again off a
solid start
yeah he's trying to uh
disobey what's meant to happen
trying to change the timeline
full metal though with the pressure
backed away oh he's trying to give him
the keeper
the one two step
it begins he's got one assist on deck
time to plant one of your five a day
here we go
all right all right thank you without
grinding
the sister coming back as well that
should be dead
goddamn the combos never
one on one
and this time it's fury taking the first
character down
yeah the long long combos never end the
story but it did come to an end ducks
two cats left kefla knee
[Music]
i feel like
most of what i've seen from jokes today
is kefla
his kefla has been a menace
yeah
the aggression is like on point i think
his kid who's very consistent but the
the kefla is catching a lot of people of
god
[Music]
oh
the beam to open him up and that's going
to be a dead end
it feels like jugs is trying to uh
you know do the the team composition
strategy so keep napa for last at the
moment oh that's a good point yeah yeah
because for the
the two matches right he beat the end
first
and now he gets really in
okay but here's
napa moustache man
fire in the booth and he
tried to yeah that's a
you i can do that to you but you can't
do dui
imagine blocking one
imagine actually blocking on this
that was the man who committed that
level 3. had the jokes blocked this one
it would have been long
that's right here exposing people polar
words in that all day jumps
oh no we stand i guess oh no that could
have been him
not happening and he's getting the
crosstalk there
full little fury keeping the leads
so not only does he got uh napa he's got
broly with spark behind
he's got me feeling pretty comfortable
here right yeah
yep that's a solid answer by jugs and
now it's the battle of the berserkers
indeed
zee bully the original berserker
vs kefla the one that was made
canon but there is sparkle that zebra
decides
indeed spark anabolic probably just
going to try and end this combo to put
in the corner oh looking for a reset i
know full metal likes to do that if you
air from there you get scooped or you
can land and get punched up in the face
brody doesn't care
he is a demon after all and
i'll always like that animation because
to me it feels like he's like here is an
l
there you go thank you
thank you very much
that is for little fury evening it up
1-1
in this set versus jerks it's the first
two three of course winner of this will
face tazer in losers final while plug is
comfortably resting
in grand finals winner site
he is he's i wonder if uh plug's
cheering on full metal i mean he might
want this timeline he might want this uh
this napa grand finals i feel it's been
a long time coming yeah absolutely
let's see
1-1
fury looking to keep that momentum it's
been a very momentum based match so far
yeah for sure right
i think judge's team obviously has a bit
more of the momentum a little more
nimble
um you've got to establish a lot of like
conditioning i feel
full metal scene before you can get the
simon stuff planted but this is a good
start
excitement
now he's gonna wait wait for the neutral
to work for you good dragon raj style
who knows the impending doom was on
route and gets the
dragon rush back into kepler okay
another success has fury blocked the 6h
i don't think so but i don't know what
happened as well yeah
guess the spark regardless jerks gonna
extend it's after vanish there's a lot
of scaling on this one the spark might
save that napa's life
it will
so go for level three good luck
all right
what's the mix and you know fury hasn't
got sparky so it's looking well
can i uh not pay royalties to you for
this one but me
[Laughter]
listen
it's almost the same words it opens
people up it's a mix
and we might see another one right now
i've got a bar in deck
and does go for hellzone this time jocks
setting them up
nothing to knock down as
furious
the flurry of attacks on kepler not let
anyone interfere and come into the arena
okay
nice getting that six h another opening
and again i don't think c4 that i've
seen fury blocking the 6h
yeah
i had to think about that's what i took
i mean i wasn't even hanging i was
thinking about it and i don't think he's
about those yeah about blocking those
all right childhood to lock her down but
not going for anything and that ui goku
b gets to pick up drugs
eliminating tien
and now it's zebra only weighs no spark
so
so at least choice has eliminated the
spark issue
yeah that's i think that is a big factor
with broly uh but he's got seven bars
there's a lot of presents he could be
giving out
looking like father christmas right now
but he needs to get a hit before any of
that can get started
oh yeah that's not a thing he's got
barrier up another one's not good
okay
oh my god
kangaroo gaming
i heard the mario jumping behind this
but it just like
dead
i i saw broly's workout routine just
squats man was doing mad squats
just up down up
she has the full metal for trying to
follow it
shout out to him for actually trying to
follow the high low but
he got bamboozled
that
man said the chris pratt jumping i hate
you guys
yo shout out
that was sick
he definitely tried to block it oh
damascus looked okay okay okay okay the
roshi is back
but
all right no game thanks for playing
guys we we're just gonna go next game
there's no power we're not watching so
how is life i'm kidding
yeah
it's kind of right i don't i don't think
that was the problem maybe he feels like
he wants to go out with roshi yeah oh
yeah he's gone to the gt team yeah
let's see let's see what that team's
saying anyway from one
bald gentleman to another one it's roshi
putting the pressure on
and don't get twisted everyone he
doesn't know about full metal he can
play rogue
he's he said he'd be waiting for roshi
from like season one yeah yeah he picked
russia's day one
like as soon as he was and i was like
yep that's my character
right now i was putting work
get
in the jar please
thank you very much closed
wrapped up goodbye kit book
damn that was the solution man instead
of going for like goku genkidama and
stuff all it took was a bottle
just seal man ultimate containment
shield
good air though kefla doesn't care about
this old man
[Music]
it's my block go straight to the spark
oh my god snipes
that's gonna be a ton of damage by the
way that's going to be a ton of damage
oh no i think he needs to come to the
tod yeah still a lot of damage like you
said yeah
i like your cuts
your neck back i had to get chucked in
the back of your neck that is that is
really weird actually now i think about
it he likes her cut man
that's all
like rare footage of wholesome roshi
happens sometimes
let's go live
he was trying to show the gangster but
he said i'm a one-man gang brother you
can't do nothing
that was wild
all right that should
take care of that roshi
boom into level three i think he's dead
i'm not sure actually i'm not sure limit
break doesn't break the supers so
oh yeah you're right so it's just a
sparkling deck yeah yeah
one pixel
the masters the shades are off though it
means business brings in the kid yeah
the young one ratatouille he's back it's
indoor season two don't readjust the
stream don't worry student coming in
the season two demon versus the season
three demon
we've all been terrorized by the issue
at some point in the game and right now
ui google takes it with the side switch
there the masses only effects that dash
out of the corner you still got these
okay
okay i see you
okay
that's good right
ah he's number one he's gonna walk so
but he's got level two oh yeah that
might be dead
so that that that was pristine gaming
gourmet bombos
served by full metal fury and it is to
all that loser semi-final is going to
the final game
will fury
ensure that the full uk top three
can jugs
keep flying
the dutch colors which as chad said
earlier as also the uk colors so like
it's
same he's actually loki
he's actually from horizontal france so
you know still flying the the coloster
i mean it's it's like ui when you're
knocking down it's our oaky it's our
colors right we all share them
it's fine we will share it together two
two i normally grill full metal for
stepping away from that bar
he's proven me wrong this roshi is going
in can juxta just yeah that was pretty
hard to say on the fly as well look at
the light wow
there we go there we go
good luck you've got to go back to
neutral trying to play with the
beams that are actually super ashes and
good ones gonna be forcing him in a
block situation good blocks by jugs he's
been blocking by like for 20 seconds
straight takes the dragon rush
and now it's almost time to block let's
see if you've got the same resilience he
does not the dr does hit kidro taking
roger to the sky
kepler's coming back to throw in an
assist if necessary and it completely
was damascus against the clip yeah here
we go the enemy from darts is so strong
right now
okay
okay we got a simple bombos or he's just
trying to bait something there not gonna
happen just yet and straight to his
oh my god snipes
let's go
i never played around but i'm um i'm
making the fan over right now
okay guard on to get away jugs
definitely feels in stress against that
roshi man but you know it jugs
secret oh my god that was not a good job
oh no this is bad luckily you know
juxta's got kid who a on his on his team
so the assist extensions aren't great so
just go straight to level three still a
good fifty percent
no spot
gonna have to block this honestly
[Music]
imagine blocking
why did i say honestly i knew silencer
said honestly i was like full mode's
gonna do something mad random imagine
blocking man he did not pay for this
game to block
there we go oh my gosh he paid 50 pounds
to press bonds not to hold directions
he's trying to get some points
[Music]
the blocks my jokes there's no assist
here for four months oh no i knew what i
think he was trying to go tag because
i've seen the cross uh going on ui goku
for for like a half a second so i think
he was trying to rotate but could not
get it at this timing and that's gonna
be a dead kefla excellent job by full
metal fury
you try sauce
you try sauce you have to have dried
chips mate
that was a sick convert
okay okay okay okay okay that was pretty
good this might be your team fan this
actually might be your team
all right deadpool
and back to ui alone no spark it's
looking quite good for fury
he's got the sticks everywhere roshi kid
boo oh but we've got windy punches jugs
is not out of it yet
one of the strongest characters in the
game here we go
we're not knocking
we are not blocking those not now
[Music]
can he kill
double two
nah
escape doesn't need a super dash
blocks for now
oh
he actually pressed buttons no jugs
frame trap block bro
oh that's dark okay we love the same
side
oh my gosh gang signs
[Applause]
[Laughter]
not like this one not like this
i was so sick
oh yeah you can't die from there
oh he's dead
well well well
that was sick honestly
that roshi
both of us were like why but he proved
us wrong
yeah yeah it wasn't that we know we know
that full mel can play rosh he was just
like but nap is so strong but
there's an argument to be had now
especially when it comes to full metal
right like is roshi's that strong and i
think that team comp suits him like very
well his gt is on point as well which i
always thought he picked gt like a lot
of people just because it was gt right
the assist uh but he stuck with gt after
the the nerfs on him so shout outs man
definitely like he did really well and
obviously so did jux taking it to three
two uh like you said the last remaining
uh player from the netherlands
took it to him but yeah fullmetal just
came on top three to one unfortunate man
pam what what a uh play what an absolute
banger of a match we just had right now
with full metal fury ensuring a top
three that is full uk shows two drugs
fourth place uh 70 points i believe on
the leaderboard for jugs we've got two
sets remaining today one of them is
gonna be taser versus full metal fury in
losers final and the winner of this will
play plug in grand finals remember that
plug being in winners means he uh
has a much more comfortable position
there
yeah for sure i mean
i'm i'm guessing taser's gonna stick
with his squad now we've seen obviously
what full metal's got in his back pocket
i don't know what he's gonna go for if
he's going to go for simon or the uh the
popeye frame traps where i'm just
being swole on screen and then frame
trapping people
with armor
i don't know what's about he has to do
what needs to be done right yeah it
seems like he's going to the napa first
of all let's see this isn't good enough
to take out taser you got knocked out
like you said by plug in winner's side
uk on uk action gotta love it yeah this
time one of the
one of these three remaining players
will get these 200 points and get pretty
much one foot
in
these regional finals the round opener
could have gone for fury but no
conversion you're gonna be forced to
block mix good luck
very good start
yeah okay so i mean full metal showing
that he can block but the takes and
reactions aren't there probably waiting
for a moment to try and escape but
just past him
and here we go again he's gonna guess
reflect
gold
we fight back
nice
okay
[Music]
dicks
did i try to explode stance
he was not doing anything he was not
doing anything and somehow he's getting
oh he got the happy birthday conversion
putting him down got to watch out what
are we waiting straight to the spark
very early spark by fury trying to save
that napa and the buttons are pressed
and the assist is available
you know what time is it
yeah
time to be a victim
[Music]
he said nope
do not pass go
collect this damage
three bars we gonna cash out
oh tell the light he's gonna get a lot
more than that and he is actually gonna
take out nappa
spark off the table for both players and
not so bad
uh but unlike the other matches
something that you played at damascus
the the order of
killing characters cases is going for
the point characters which does lead
tien anger yeah oh my god look at these
big muscles
look at this massive spectrum is it dead
um maybe
good one fury immediately evens this one
up
and try to go for the ray but not gonna
go anywhere i've got my own it's my 5s
and that's why goku oh my these are
advanced mixes
that's so good
yeah and full metal
getting hit by the loki
the no mix mix here we go take them down
but not a [ __ ] kill
wake up scratch freckles
and brings in broly put back in the
corner yes please
all right
full screen just waiting
oh my god that was actually so smart
that was actually so smart to go for the
2h to beat
that that hit a assist and with this
fury should be able to get the kill and
i think he wants to keep rolling in
right we all if we kill with this it
should right
yeah that'll be enough that'll be enough
yeah
excellent play by fury looking to clutch
this game on
it's mad i mean full metal definitely
look like they're on the back foot but
he really doesn't just rely on that
tap tap knock knock who's there
it's the dire thumb
get hit uh four bars
i wonder if four-bar shotgun would have
killed her
i think sorry i think so
i mean this isn't gonna kill right no
i think four bars are gonna have kills
but you know what i don't care put my
hands in my pockets
slippery floor
there is no sign telling you so and we
go to the one touch territory
oh my god
[Music]
scratching records djtn
that's it
show me guys
[Music]
it's so funny that you literally just
saw jump jab
and looked at the bar and then knew he
was dead yeah that's cool i was already
updating the score as i get cool okay
the first one ggs thank you cheers
got a hit he's got more than five bars i
guess it's one nil didn't it yep like
gods easy maps c4
the scripts
the scripts e4
did i actually speed it to resistance
i'm so scared oh my god
i'm so upset but yeah we full metal is
definitely trying to rewrite history
we'll write his own history trying to
get the grandfather from losers
oh he's planning yep taser knows his
time to go in because he wins neutral
but he won it anyway
all right what do we got for us
boom plants
and now we got to watch out because our
minds coming at some points he's still
there
good movement by taser to get away from
the from the cyberman menace
yes 100
the acknowledgement of oh yeah i i can't
approach on the ground even though my
character is a you know a ground-based
character and look at this
wait was that crosstalk don't tell me
that was crossover if that's what
i cried
oh my god
i if if if i catch anyone talking about
and that has no neutral to her again i
might explode
i'm gonna have to get a burner account i
don't want to ever hear this character
is neutral he plants neutral that's the
best mechanic i've ever known in the
fine game
i'm telling you we are outsourcing
neutral this is what we do here
why why play neutral when you can just
like pay people for cheap you pay them
nothing you pay them half a bar and they
do the neutral for you
argent
actual bargain
i don't know man 214 and pick any button
you like and we do it for you
amazing
trusted trader absolutely trusted trader
spot
plasma on screen and another one planted
you don't want to go that way taser he's
close
good that i respect the hell out of that
spark because it was about to be very
long great to him on this and i think he
should build enough to kill
no oh no
don't go for reach yeah keep it simple
keep it simple now if you're purely he's
not that kind of guy you know he's
yeah he's not black
oh he's reaching through the soup oh no
he's tearing back actually he's got t on
his team sorry guys
there was no calculations to do that he
was always he said he's there but tensor
heat was like oh nice gun you got there
but let me show you my bazooka
yeah
this is how you do damage fun
all right
you think this is a knife this is a nice
joke advice it's too many
youngins in the chat
all right
five bars i think he can kill the end
yeah he got hit again
nice that should be enough oh it's gonna
be close
ah
i think he's alive
guess what the lights cool amazing thank
you 69
thank you ggs
all right
it's definitely
because that's the one situation man not
gonna kill of course but tonight oh my
god
so sick oh i don't know if you wanted
that side swap though
he'll take it he'll make
no
fury what are you doing
he's
well he's pitching this isn't even
thrown he's actually just pitching he's
throwing this
full
throttle at taser to win it a lot of
blue health on his side good zone tight
all right
let's see what you got hey zoro is not
gonna get to level three for this one
so putting you in a situation wait oh no
fury stop blocking with your face
you got one more guest he's alive he's
like yes i think he's like
he's at the corner as well and he
doesn't have to worry about vanish
but
actually
no he's like one touchy
that should be a safety right
oh my
i never knew that i didn't reach well
vanish you're an animal do it again
random
reflect he's a genius he's the best
player on the planet the masters he
didn't wake up slow present
how are you guys real question
entertainment
you're gonna get tired i'm bad i can't
oh yo full metal never changed my guy
never ever changed
yo he he actually installed fear into
taser oh that level three
i've never seen anyone do
something so big brained oh
my god
my god these games are ridiculous let's
go fury one game away from giving a
grand
finals full of nappas can he make it
happen for now is taser with the first
blood
i'm still i'm still dying from the first
game man yeah i'm trying to i'm trying
to compose myself it's pretty hard okay
let me get back into this game
full metal fury
with so much metal damage on taser i
don't think he could lose i think it's
impossible for us
he's just got the three on the board
this is going in look at
him
i don't maybe tate has checked out from
that last game
you know like it's hard for taser as
well right we haven't mentioned this but
losing this way is bound
to tilt
you he's playing in the plank position
right now he is mad to it
he has to be right
you know being tilted against yuri is
one of the hardest thing in the world
trying to go for the invisible dragon
rush but no
nice one to just get away yep good
movement there by tesla oh he tried to
go for the cheeky little reset it's not
gonna happen
and with this
we'll go back to napa
he should be able to plant
whoa watch out watch out subway
watch out oh he's left left right he's
looking good his job he was gone
not going
oh no i didn't get oh yeah here we go
trying to stop all that momentum he's
trying to give him a clap c4 c4
okay it's not going to happen it's not
going to happen
yeah i think he's got that yeah he's
done he's over time he's going back on
walking kids in
let's go level three
mix behind very important one to try and
kill that tapper
no
i think okay
it took a while
but
fury has decided to never block on wake
up and it works
taser looks like he's finally adapting
forcing him to block
yeah i think that's where he is right i
think also you know four miles two games
up thinking that
they can do more buttons and likely
scene you know what
if the 30 don't succeed ll again and it
works drops the combo though
oh my gosh he's yeah not like this man
[Applause]
[Music]
fury
you're gonna have to install tetris in
your games man
i know you're losing wind uh loses
finals but
this might be a skill especially if
you're thinking about going against plug
you might want to learn how to block my
guy
oh
big whiffing wow
i guess it was so much blocked on store
all right
taser looking okay but
actually it's it's a two-touch game on
both sides so
100 too fast gaming
all right reflected on par
don't throw them out too red delete he's
in
good tech
oh no there's nothing in the conversion
with this one
and he had committed to a jump
we got to watch out i like the movement
from taser right now he's not taking any
risk he's really trying to beat
ending up but watch out for these super
dashes
few yep oh no that was death no no
polish because that was definitely not
on purpose i think that was an assist
call but you know what we take this
level
and he needs to be careful but it's it's
funny because full metal does play
tien a little bit like that but you
gotta be worried there's two h's but the
dragon rush does hit
or does he level three
yeah
okay
yeah he wants he wants a guaranteed so i
respect that
and he has a better assist in the back
right gog
i think
i think he's still alive he's not gonna
build i don't know what he's almost
alone
yeah he's gonna get that ball oh no he's
got 0.99 bars man oh no get out get out
get out get out get out we got
still alive
and i think i think it all comes down to
that c4
like it's easy to get frustrated when
you play
and fury caught on that and was like you
know what i see he's frustrated i'm
gonna press buttons
and it worked but now taser took a
moment
and was like hold up
he's not blocking why am i giving him
turns that don't exist
let me force him to block and that
definitely works t1
taser
looking a bit better
can he bring it to a game five
yeah i think you're right you know what
the most impressive thing about it is
that he did that in the last game in the
middle of the match because he was just
getting matched on at the beginning he
lost the character went okay game plan
time let's do this 2-1
can still make this comeback i was wrong
don't put the three on full metals
fury's name quite yet he's gonna have to
earn it
as he goes into this fourth
match x
mix
mixed
that's it your sister back you got
tiered on your team
no hit some decay you didn't go for the
right combo
oh my god
point
blink
break
just blink
everyone gets it man
okay we take those that's okay
empty shot and see yeah frame kill into
and you could see the counter because
you saw that fury woke up buttons
and now that's the question
right
is fury just pressing buttons on wake up
or is he looking to adapt to his
opponents
and that's a huge question you know
we still don't know he's only getting to
full metal
it's like is it calculated or is it
random
okay
oh my god what a sniper
is ascending
i've got the century beam he gets a
okay hey confirmed
okay it's full met with sending this
wall with the blocks he's not pressing
buttons he's waiting
shout casters
benediction
my bad i'll owe you a
drink next time
it'd be like that
expensive frame kill there
uh
we take those why not yeah
yes
yeah jason's not paying rent anymore
it's uh full mail's paying rent in his
mind like he's in there
oh my god he actually reflected see once
again no block
the taser is not taking advantage of
this for now
because napa is going to put him down
into a shmixturization situation
good spark
that's the one and decides to go for a
no tech blue combo very low damage there
yeah extending it kind of wastes another
one spark i'm just pulling some bar on
the way
and these are dead
oh i don't can you kill from there yeah
you can well that's it i
i expected that combo to be extremely
low damage but taser proved me wrong
he's playing really really good it's a
2v2 right now
yeah enough around the picture but we've
seen already full metal can definitely
play
tien and broly gonna have to be scared
of the anchor broly and he's got seven
bars oh my gosh he tried to dj him
kelly's not in the building but no
oh my god
oh
oh my gosh wake up
he doesn't care
i'm still i am still waiting for the
that wake up block c4
no confirmation
i like the idea it just didn't work and
now it's done too he's on to z bully
taser looking to offer us a game number
five
man
this i feel stressful for both players
because this is this is the boney
remember
remember if you block zebrale's 5l it's
mixed
you're not wrong
right now though
taser not need to do any blocking as he
gets his confirmed that's two bars
extension dragon rush
i think he's alive
yes he's one touchy
and he only needs his amount of luck to
make a comeback be very careful because
everyone's getting slapped up he made me
go i had the birthday damascus i mean he
lost my mind that would have been
massive
but hand him the l and now it's 1v1 and
i know broly has no life but he's got so
much bar
that one hits can be death is he gonna
cheat you please don't cheat you around
start don't you dare
okay
[Laughter]
oh my god
the wind was handed to him
he just was not ready
yeah yeah because it looked like he was
baiting the vanish right he staggered
and waited
and then yeah you just didn't react to i
mean it's a high pressure situation
brother i
i can't fault him for it it's a very
stressful scenario to be in on both
sides ui versus broly no one's winning
except the spectators right yeah
yeah
let's see let's see this
final game
it's too old
fury not switching to the roshi team
keeping
napa looking to give us a full napa
grand finals or taser looking for maybe
a run back versus plug for now we're
blocking
i mean i mean
taser is blocking not not weak
let's not let's not assume what people
want to do
player 2 is blocking for sure
maybe not by choice it's just napa
pressure it forces you to do that oh
we're planning we are establishing
neutral shut up
business partner
oh god there's something to me
nope is this a thing you can punish it
right sure no no no no
is safe
so yeah like expensive but save the hc
shout outs to where i think i saw wade
do that yeah hey wade is the one who
taught me this that you are into hits
he's safe
oh my god
this c4 this is bullying
he actually plays every character on
that point he doesn't run up too hate
with everyone if you don't know is that
mixed what can i say all right oh my god
he was so angry i'm still looking for
wake up blockers before
don't worry man you can't find it i'm
still waiting for
i'm still waiting
i don't know i think when i'm done with
this stream i'm gonna turn on minecraft
and be like damn i missed these blocks
man i haven't seen any today
oh and this is i mean full metal does
have spark but no broly in the back he's
gonna have to do this with napa and tien
the ball guys are in the building and
deciding to do it damascus i think he
can kill of course
behind fun
i don't know why i said things forgive
me chat they give me the message i'm
sorry c3 for a hundred percent that's
definitely a c3 monument chief
[Music]
oh my god my man was like 5h eats that
left arm of the forbidden one
i think you're dead two and one two and
three
oh no he goes for three i wonder if two
and three would have killed
can you you can do one into shotgun
right but
oh yes you can now because the character
is dead i forgot about this patch notes
maybe taser should have checked them out
because you're a hundred percent right
he could have killed and now he's
getting naftered
oh mix season two mix oh no good no no
conversion
oh this is long
oh this is length
this is gogeta blue 2m
this is mad this is
the longest you need to eliminate that
napa as soon as possible
vanish
oh no spark sparks no one does too low
it was too low when you're higher you
can get that to combo he was way too low
oh no he might have and that's massive
for taser because this is the level 2
spark
much shorter than level 31 and just like
that you go for the longest combo fury
do not regret that bad spark choice you
had the killing combo don't think about
it get back into the game level free
time fury for the love of gods hold back
the battle is going to please eat it i
mean this is easier said than done and
this is ui he's got a lot of options
just level three
the problem
[Laughter]
his power level's too high
he did it i can't believe i said it and
he did it
he got to finals
i know this isn't in the run time can we
get another break bro
i wasn't ready for this
let me let me let me i need i need
hydration
[Music]
i've actually got tears my eyes this is
this has been actually the same stuff i
think i've ever seen
oh my god
let me drink in peace man
i don't know myself
[Music]
i swear
i swear if fury wins this
if you win this i'm sending him a steam
gift card with like tetris effect
i'm like minecraft yes you have to
you have to oh i'm gonna say i'm gonna
get his address and send him a lego
starter set
oh go out of my iceberg
i have a jenga game in my house i'm
going to send it to him
i can't like
i mean you said it right and you called
it out but it works like he's just got a
team full of armor bruh
he's seen the floor you've called it out
and no one could do anything about it
because everything has armor
exactly he
what do you do
well i'll
okay we calibrate composure let's check
this bracket out let me update that
bracket because i have not so yeah it is
too much
so that's three two
four full little fury and he is going to
face
plug
in a full
napa
grand finals
it happened it actually happened i'm
i'm not taking responsibility
i'm not taking possibility i just said
it would have been funny if it would be
plugged
i didn't wish this but i'm happy we're
here bro because these two players have
been grinding for the longest tv fair
for the longest over here in the uk when
it comes to online and offline clearly
an apple mastery on both sides but full
metal with the pocket roshi and the most
extraordinary extravagant
read and plays
in dragon ball
i'm seeing the genius idea in the chat
by nick v
so
when you have a napa mirror you just put
both napa full screen and both of them
plan to hate cyberman because you can
choose the input sequence and you just
send them to fight like pokemon
[Laughter]
yo
oh you know what this actually might
happen because i know that i know full
metal's messaging plug to do something
like this a hundred percent
if you saw if anyone followed full metal
he tweeted that he's like oh i guess i'm
in top eight i'm only here to cheer on
plug so he's actually just gonna meme i
hope they both me i hope they do that i
hope we see some pokemon battles digimon
whatever i just want back up key charge
back up
so make sure to get the half the bar
then they go bro oh my god
what
what a day it's been so far dragon ball
fighters this has been a lot of fun i
hope
you guys are having as much fun as we
are because like right now it's been a
ton of fun the players are ready we got
plug
in the winner side so plug only needs to
win three games and for little fury
being on the loser side he will need to
reset the bracket
and
win another first two three he needs to
win two first two threes
against plug the grand final
has two napa players in who
would have thought
this is what we deserve
we spent too long moving about now for
being seated this is actually what we
deserve where why are my serves on the
shot can i have can i feel can you fill
that chat with knappers
please we got we got the perfect emote
for this yep we got the absolute perfect
emote for this and i'm seeing that plug
is picking the videl
is he
he's gonna be delta
he's gonna be dealt him yeah yeah i mean
it's not his main team but yeah he's not
like he can't play though he can
definitely play bedell he played the
dole in season two yeah
yeah but obviously not having to reflect
no she does you know yes
yeah no she does so oh there we go
so like whatever you want yeah
c4 i think i think
yeah oh and he's going for quite yet oh
my
i told you i saw the tweet these two
players are literally one hive whined
nappa
point nappa this means one thing we're
gonna do a dance
[Music]
yes you betrayed him
[Laughter]
there's a hundred points on the line
full metal please
i'm praying
all right
go watch these tears i'll try and
commentate videl
short hair festival by the way
he portrayed the plan you can trade the
pound 100 percent don't meant to back up
and do something
and full metal went 100 points on the
line my chords let's go
all right okay
wait which cyberman is this oh that's a
it makes perfect sense it only doesn't
make sense when you don't see who's
doing it yeah yeah all right crossover
and fury
guess the kill
it's now time for fidel
no napa gaming right now both players
without the the planner can we get with
punish unfortunate 6m gets blocked oh
where are you dodging
my three jumps gets close
okay
nice guess to pick up as well you can't
counter vanish a uh vanish in spark how
much damage can he get with this he gets
the region that's dead
yeah like he said
one can actually play this character you
don't see it often but
don't sleep on the short head the dell
just the power plug has that in win
aside bringing you the dell and double
nappers only eu
this is this is a very unique oh nice
one against the elbow as well or just
gonna go for the soft knot down there
still if he does behind to play with not
gonna
amount to anything right now dice
movement by plug no conversion but
that's what you aim that is going to be
a ton of damage and probably
dead
a 1-1 should be enough here
nice one plug
the betrayal was attempted
and he's like
we are napa players man we are fair and
honest individuals
until the cyber man is planted
you know you you broke
rule one of napa
never betray nappa
yeah he definitely uh
i think he
i don't even know anymore
what what do you say i'm interested
if plugged on the stick with napoleon
points i think he only got now from
point to uh
for the culture for the discord
for the discord well plug one you can't
change your team after you won so
you know you
you you your team your tv remains the
same after you win tournament rules
you can't change
let's see
i wanted to do it again
okay
i'll get super dash and he's gonna stay
in the air yeah a bit outside of that
cyberman damn
yep and full metal does recognize the
spacing goes in on the doe another
shout out to the box
he actually left the screen like his
entire box
disappeared
[Laughter]
oh my god this is a great i'm spent i
don't know about you guys but i am
spending a great
great
great sunday evening so far yo
this is getting that to every playlist i
have
every playlist even audio ones but just
just to hear this this is so sick oh we
did it again goes into dp
hey you know what i want to see with
videl
because fury presses buttons and wake up
all the time i want plug to go he's wake
up and to do reflect but we know dodge
yeah that that that would be statement
but you know what i don't care because
we didn't stay
yeah the dog might get that next round
yeah oh no
oh my
i'm tired damascus
[Laughter]
it's been a fun day
it has it's it's been a fun day all the
6 a.m
what's the mix behind
[Applause]
yeah this has to be the uh oh my gosh
the slow one or the blue combo but he
doesn't care about the color of the
numbers
okay
fury should be able to kill that napa
now stop into level one
ascending and he gets napa in right now
to go for the combo no just plants
uh he he oh my god
new monster so he he punched the
cyberman out then went forward to edge
damn
yeah i think that uh so hitting the
submarine actually let you cancel oh my
god
i told you he played every character
like that run up to h nothing just yet
one touch good block no he's gonna get
the low and just like that
fury
he's going to take game number two it is
one one
in this grand finals now plug can change
teams
right i i think plug will probably keep
it until
well if the bracket gets reset i think
he will play out video
we know
plug is uh
he he's got a lot of
teams that help napa so he's got like a
beerus and stuff oh he's just changing
the order okay he's just changing order
okay he's just putting video points all
right well
will uh he believes in that video so
let's see what
you get for this plug
in winners needs two games full metal
fury in his two games to reset the
bracket and gives us an extra first two
three
please
i would definitely i would love this you
know but you know think about plug man
yeah think about plugs metal
okay
a little bit of damage here had to spend
both assists but ouch wasn't finished
mix yourself up you played yourself
oh lots of drops on both sides oh
nice one this is the dodge andy's
putting him down
yeah he's trying to bait the wake-up
options there he did but no punish vlog
at least
looking to just like bait his wake-up
options there
the movement oh he actually punched him
out
right that's really strong from the door
now
oh he tried but the buttons were pressed
that's gonna be a solid amount of damage
for
fury what a freestyle parkour combo than
i said that was sick
he's still down there right oh no oh
that's going to be huge by the way
she's in spark oh he dropped that's okay
drop opportunities
dropper tuning is indeed frankensteiner
into nappa
and
full metal
got some work to do here no spark so if
you get hit by napa
people going to be looking at you
thinking okay let's see how you like it
oh that was a nice jumping as well and
you know what's going to put him into
the corner gets the video assistant you
know what time is it
oh he see uh he already had a cyberman
so yeah he can't yeah go for the mix
just yet but the other side man is
coming out you're forced to block right
now reflect oh he punched the cyberman
out but watch out and the pressure is
still on plug getting the opening
extending he's got both assists
available that should be a dead zebrally
i believe so as long as he doesn't drop
it which he doesn't yeah
here we go
okay looking pretty comfortable here for
plug
only having tn left i think probably
full metals weakest characteristic at
least time with tien but the damage is
real no matter how long you've been
playing the character so just needs to
land that hit oh that was sick just
needs to land that hit but it's not
gonna happen just yet that's going to be
a dead videl tien
putting in work and it's napa in now the
battle of the bald man
indeed indeed oh here we go
casey grove medicine full metal can you
deal with it
oh good luck
oh nice gets to cross up as well
and with the is it
oh the sideline is still there and it
steals the corner so it won't let you go
into the corner he actually wanted a a
very well combo to be honest i think he
wanted that truthy success into cyberman
speed but not entirely sure what chad
simon's coming the reflect nice
[Music]
full mail can do with his own
shenanigans john look at the damage
he's dead
oh well i lied
i still think you're right someone's
dead damascus someone is going to be
bragging
one more hit
[Music]
it actually does not and that is going
to be a dead end the choice was pretty
much right but unfortunately with plug
offers himself two match points two
tournament points plug
looking
to be
the winner of today's tournament and the
fact that he also won back-to-back
tournaments before this fight winner
stays on and on the online tournament
which name i don't remember that was
against the asha in grand finals uh
plug is establishing himself
as
one of the best
you can get around
yeah not a fluke he's no joke
uh
definitely
providing good knowledge to all players
and that playing nappa and showing
that he can practically do those things
but full metal has drifted back to his
roshi okay this is something that helped
him get to this spot right damascus so
what a rock right
popped by the sailor man what are you
saying
what starts
this is not a grunt for napa grand
finals anymore
as napa is out on fury side but the
pressure is there how
much do you know about videl though
that's a very good question would you
know about this gang sign
master roshi
swinging not going to be enough to kill
probably keep gt for pressure
[Applause]
oh all right do you have ah
no happy birthday there so he at least
gets a solid amount of damage on this
putting that roshi that he's trying to
bait something on wake up straight to
the spark the blue light is recovered
nice i like the idea i like the idea but
i was clean by the
by plug
gonna hang in there
oh left right time nice
all right
i should be five
yeah 113.
oh no
baba swing
one and three
yep and that is going to be a dead video
fury taking the leads
and like when fury plays his team he
plays so differently yeah it's like two
different players yep
definitely hard to
adapt to his undergo as well now
and that is what so what that's one of
the things plug likes is like it's a
jumpy blast into the assistant that
guarantees him a plant and the armor is
going to work on this
what can he get with the cyberman right
now
that was woke man why are napa players
brain so big
block that from it
all right
how much can you get with this you're
gonna get the re-jump nope nope nope
nope you're gonna drop the re-jump that
is not gonna happen just yet
i'm just gonna wait for now great take
my plug waiting full screen oh that was
kinda bait because of the blue life
surprise plot did not go for patience on
this one and he's putting the sandwich
situation cyberman is still there
oh my god oh my gosh he got absolutely
sparked out of that cover me up
is he gonna get enough here to kill i
think so
[Applause]
oh my god
that was such a sick confirm
i'm sure he had to freestyle that right
because he planted that sudden time ago
let's see 2v2
try to get in good reflect
forcing there oh that was a nice way to
avoid that one the sideman is planted is
not going to come out just yet
yeah he's going to wait until napa
recovers from this knockdown which is
now he tries movements
he tries movements
there's an assist he's not gonna go for
the region this time
how much can you get here he's not gonna
kill with this right so gets the
cyberman oh no that was bad oh that's
gonna be big damage
unless the submarine ruins the combo
which
is a possibility no not with another
plug oh no jk don't you please don't
shoot you it's not worth it
i love cyberman is now a natural counter
to broly he's like oh oh you got kevlar
no there you go the opening
plug gonna go for the extension there
just to set as much as he can
probably swapping to blurry questions he
can on this
hold up
remain in damascus
full metals
tournament run relies on the season two
god himself can he make it happen
wow
all that ll was enough it used to be but
full metal i've got something what a
attack
what attack on this plug he's looking
for his final hit he's looking to get
that win not just yet fury
trying to save his life in tournaments
your plug has been elusive you're so
lucky he blocked that but the defense is
showing off
that plug is more than just office ah he
tried to charge it's not gonna work and
just like that plug
once again
wins the big tournament
that is gonna be 3-1
plug will be your champion
for the europe 2 region 200 points
in his back pockets and one foot
in the regional finals
what an incredible play
by plug
he's literally
been unstoppable the last three
tournaments
yeah five
that's three terms centered three one
right
like that that's how it goes so plug
is going to take 200 points
and you know plug is going to enter
every single tournament there is for the
uk there is good as dragon ball next
week which is one of the 10k qualifiers
everyone can apply of course remember to
run some of these qualifiers and give
some more points to the players but plug
after the display today
it's going to be difficult for the uk
uh and netherlands uk island netherlands
contender
to
try and overtake plugs on the
leaderboard damn
yeah extremely hard like for the reason
you said right not just that because
he's a good player like the free tone if
you talk about they were online and
offline yeah like
ek is for anyone and like damascus said
he's going to be entering he's got you
think because he's got 200 like points
he's not going to come to your
tournament and mix you with simon no
he's coming
he's definitely coming for all the
points but uh chad's the full met will
come in second and look at that losers
run
that's crazy honestly
like let's remember that fury started
top eights
he started top eight in losers right so
he had a ton of work to do had to take
wolf shadow face al dante drugs taser
and then lost to plug in grandfather
what an incredible run
mental that's like a that's like a
hero's journey right because only one of
those matches at the bottom were last
game yeah you won two one three two
three two yeah
he's played the most games yeah he's
he's had a lot of fun uh playing today
but
unfortunately not getting the win but
regardless c4 he is getting
150 points he will sit seconds in the
leaderboards for europe too so still you
know a strong chance uh what he needs
now is to win tournaments over
plug and it's going to be hard of course
because you mentioned how enjoy plug
currently is but that will close today
the eu 2 master event 200 points taken
by plug yesterday was eu4 with the 200
points taken by uh panda from germany
and for the entire month of october guys
every single weekend we when i say we
but like we're not going to be on the
stream there are plenty of events plenty
of commentators and stuff uh but
every single weekend in october we will
be on this channel twitch.tv shout out
fighters to run all of the master events
uh we had euphoria u2 today last week
was west coast next week on sunday is
the japan masters
right that's going to be me and taranton
commentary uh
in two weeks it's the eu three masters
so that's portugal spain and italy so
you can expect to see the scarlet abu
mission from italy the miami berserker
from spain kenya from portugal you
should see like or not should be a lot
of fun for this one and then in uh three
weeks it's going to be the masters
friends
on 24th of october and sorry in two
weeks
in three weeks stories master east coast
and then
in four weeks
it's master france
so in order for the next four weeks
first week is japan
second week in spain third week is east
coast fourth week is france every single
weekend
is some good dragon ball fighters here
on this channel but of course if you
guys like dragon ball fighters it's like
drone fighters everywhere c4 in the
tournament every monday i run one every
tuesday it's usually lost on commentary
as well so like same same vibes pretty
cool so if you guys want to come and
have some fun i don't choose the ac4
we got not only do we have kaiden versus
wade
not only do we have kane playing the
winner of this we also have the return
of yasha on wantings
so
tuesday is about to be an absolute
banger cards
do make sure you join us my stream on
tuesday join c4 stream
on mondays for cbk you can enter
tournaments have some fun and of course
for the official tournaments there is
not only japan next week but there are
plenty of events in every single region
because the tier worldwide are
absolutely pulling up
man too much
too much this is like kind of the start
as well this this tournament has
i think been the most craziest thing
i've ever not just bad witness to but i
had the pleasure of doing it with
damascus and commentating that was like
insane fun i was obviously looking
really forward to doing it because it's
my region but
that was just
mind-blowingly hilarious like shout outs
to all the players that ended chat
everyone in the chat and uh yeah it's
like just like long-lived the ten catchy
series like until we get all the offline
stuff happening in a couple of months
this this is just going to be epic of
course remember guys that we are all of
these all of these tournaments are
giving points for the regional finals
regional friends are in december you've
got three weeks back to back in december
of offline goodness the first week is
the europe finals the second week is the
uh america finals and third week is the
japan finals three weeks of plenty of
dragon ball fighterz you know we got the
action it's a good time to be a
dragonball fighters fan we got a ton of
content on every channel around the
world plenty of ways to have some fun
but for today the big winner of the day
is plugged with 200 points big gigi is
to plug we're looking forward to see
your performances in the next tournament
and see if you can go all the way to
regional finals that should be it for us
guys c4 thank you so much for joining me
today i've got to say i've had a lot of
fun today man
yeah this has been like
a blast for sure i
wasn't anticipating so much madness i
didn't see a napa grand finals even
though i said it but yeah chad's all the
place for sure um
real sick
man i just can't wait for it all these
next events that are coming up on the
weekend exactly
my calendar is full man i'm not missing
any more after this one i ain't missing
anymore we're not missing anything man
japan next week on sunday until then
guys stay safe have fun thank you so
much for joining us today big gigi's
again to plug for the win today to panda
for the win yesterday to zain for the
win last week for uh the west coast and
you know we're gonna crown more
champions over the next few weeks but
for now it's done for the day thank you
so much guys for joining i will see you
very soon either on my channel for
dragon fighters or of course here on
dragon fighters i'm i'm i'm streaming
it's my channel too now having some fun
but a lot of fun to be there guys much
love everyone have a great evening ggs
to plug and remember
napa is sit here
[Music]
you